You
recognize this man as the voice saying the Joe Rogan podcast,
check it out.
You might know him from the UFC,
one of the top welterweight contenders in the world.
You might know him from Metamorris,
which is probably the premiere grappling event in North America.
We just competed this past weekend.
Brian McDonald,
ladies and gentlemen,
somebody now much man,
thanks for having me.
Thanks for doing this.
So you're in town,
you,
uh,
you did some competing at metamorris against such a tourist who saw top level
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu competitor.
Yeah,
really,
really good.
And that's unusual that a guy who's in your position who's a top welterweight
contender in MMA decides to test himself in Brazilian Jujitsu.
Why,
why did you decide to do that?
I think I want to test myself in as many martial arts as I can.
That's why I kinda got into it and why I started fighting,
you know,
the whole competitive and testing my martial arts skill against someone else at
the highest level,
you know?
So,
uh,
metamorris was a great setup.
I like the rules,
the concept of it.
So I asked if I could be a part of it and you know,
all worked out.
Oh that's cool.
So you approach them?
Yeah.
That's interesting man.
You know Metamorris F for folks who don't know the idea behind it is they don't
have any points which I like.
I like that.
Um,
I almost kind of wish they had no time limit.
You know,
like the time limit is kind of like real Jujitsu.
Like when you talked to like hoists are you talk to,
you know,
a Leo back in the day they would do it.
Say you know that especially in mixed martial arts,
they need time.
Like they're all about just a war of attrition.
Just slowly but surely keeping a pace on a guy until he makes a mistake and then
you eventually catch them.
But a lot of the metamorris are matches like yours w go to draw cause after 20
it's 20 minute time limit for yours.
Yep.
They go to 20 minute time limit and if no one has submitted each other,
it winds up being a draw.
But you guys were both going for it.
It was only a draw because the timer now me were you attacked with a leg lock
that got pretty close?
He attacked with Kamora.
I mean it was a pretty wild fast paced match.
Yeah,
there was a lot that happened.
If there was points he would have definitely beat me.
But uh,
you know,
like you were saying,
it's,
it's nice to have no points so you can maybe you're more comfortable working on
a sack patrol on the bottom rather than guard or so you're not too worried about
letting him pass or getting mount or something,
you know.
So like if you've seen,
um,
Gary Tonin,
he lets guys mountain biking leg lock him.
I train with that guy.
I won't mount him cause you know,
it's uh,
I like the,
like what does he do?
Does he do the legs over the top and does he know?
He does.
How does he,
he does like a kipping a thing with his legs.
He'll get his hips underneath of you.
Then Hill Hill,
uh,
what are the Asher grammy take the leg.
So he goes sideways.
So he almost doesn't want 80 and takes the leg.
Oh yeah.
If you watched the match,
you'll see him do it.
There's a lot of guys that are coming up with all these wild techniques now.
I was just watching some,
uh,
Jeff Glover has some crazy new technique where he goes from being caught inside
control to a heal hook.
He like,
he was demonstrating it,
but it's just the beautiful thing about Jujitsu,
one of the most amazing things about you git to is it seems to be constantly
changing and evolving.
Like MMA is evolving and changing constantly in MMA is constantly incorporating
techniques that we already knew worked in in martial arts,
like,
uh,
whether it's AI techniques or taekwondo techniques and you're seeing all these
being introduced into MMA,
but we're not seeing like new striking techniques.
The techniques have kind of been around for a long time.
Whereas with Jujitsu it's like,
it seems like it never ends.
Yeah.
If you're away for like five months here,
you're behind the ball big time because there's so much going on all the time.
Isn't that weird?
Yeah,
it's weird.
It's a crazy,
but it's exciting.
It's exciting to be a part of what's one of my favorite,
uh,
martial arts?
Cause I just think that it's,
there's a lot of good things about it where,
first of all,
it's the martial art where a small person can beat a big person.
Because when you watch like a Bruce Lee movie and you see some little guy just
throwing flying kicks and knocking out all these big dudes,
the reality of it is that,
that there's a reason for weight classes and one of the big reasons is like for
striking and for just overwhelming someone.
Yeah,
weight classes are important,
but I've seen time and time again,
smaller guys submit bigger guys and Jujitsu and that was the whole thing that
was so impressive about hoists Gracie and their early days of the UFC since they
didn't know Jujitsu,
he was submitting guys were way bigger and stronger than him.
Yeah.
That's the great thing about you Jitsu.
You know,
when I started,
I was a tiny little kid,
smaller than average when I first started at martial arts.
And that's why I took the Jujitsu so fast because I was able to neutralize or
even beat bigger guys.
Yeah.
Which doesn't really,
I mean,
you very rarely see that in kickboxing and guy has to be like way better.
Yeah.
They can overwhelm you with their power and size and smother you.
Right?
Like Bob Sapp versus Ernesto hoost.
So perfect example.
I've never seen that match.
Uh,
Jamie,
pull that up.
So people get,
I don't know if that'll get us pull from youtube.
That's whenever we say pulled from Youtube.
People are,
uh,
taking shots now they're going to die.
Uh,
we'll,
we'll pull it up.
So you get a people,
well,
if you've,
if you listening to this,
just Google Bob sat versus Ernesto hoost and what Ernesto hoost was former k one
grand Prix champion,
one of the most technical kickboxers ever in the history of kickboxing.
He was just a,
and he's actually fighting again now,
which is pretty incredible,
but he was just a,
an amazing technical kickboxer.
And uh,
he embodied that Dutch style of kickboxing,
very strong,
low kicks,
really good boxing.
And he fought this guy named Bob Sapp who was a former football player who was
99% steroids.
I mean he lives as Jews to the tits as a person he get,
he was 350 pounds with abs and doesn't even look like a real person.
Like when you see him get like that can't be real.
He's so big.
And all he did was just overwhelm Ernesto who was just push him into the corner
and just kinda donkey Kong them much technique there.
No,
very little.
I mean it's all just size and mass and I mean even the way he's throwing his
punches,
he just winging his punches and he's one of the few guys that fade or milling
and inco allegedly passed on fighting.
He didn't want to fight him.
He just said,
listen to come on and stop.
Cause you know,
Alfredo was the heavyweight champion.
He fought big guys.
He fought semi shelt.
Um,
he fought that,
that giant Korean dude.
What was his name?
The guy was literally a giant.
Remember that guy?
He fought big guys.
You know,
in a small ring.
It's not ideal for more technical guy either.
Right.
You just get pushed up against the ropes.
He can't do anything there.
So SAP eventually goes down from a,
I think a leg kick or a left hook to the body.
He got hit with something.
But to his credit,
he got up and I think it was the leg kicks.
Ernesto hoost is just so beautiful and his technique,
but he was being outweighed by about 150 pounds,
which is not a small guy.
No,
I mean he's a heavyweight.
And uh,
there's just an example of the difference between like say Jujitsu and
kickboxing,
because if this was like Hixon Gracie in his prime versus Bob Sapp and it was
just a,
a Jujitsu match,
he would eventually get them.
He would hang on to them.
Yeah.
So it was a leg kicked.
It dropped him.
It looks like he was never good at taking damage.
Bob Sapp.
No,
he was not.
Well,
he,
you know,
he had a relatively short time in fighting.
And then along the way what he did was he,
you know,
kind of just started taking dives like you would get hit.
I mean yeah,
I mean he'd sell the fights and you know,
make a big hype out of it and then somewhere along the line he just kind of,
you know,
we get hit and then he would go down in a fetal position but I think they
stopped the fight right here.
Look,
it goes down.
It's incredible.
Anyway,
we don't have to watch the rest of it,
but it's the best example of the difference between Jujitsu and say kickboxing
or,
or striking where the size can make a pretty big difference cause skill wise,
I mean you're dealing with like a blue belt there,
a black belt in her Nasta who's to Jujitsu is also this martial art where
leverage and technique and positions.
It's,
it seems to be like this continual flow of techniques.
Like you never,
you,
you've never learned enough,
you've never gotten good enough.
And even guys who have been around it a long time,
when they stop learning,
they stop applying new techniques to their game.
You see them get beaten by young guys that have all this,
these new techniques that they're just not familiar with the positions,
right.
Yeah.
Uh,
the,
the Jujitsu now,
it's definitely a lot different.
You know,
when I go to New York and train it,
hence those,
like there's always something new that catches me by surprise for the first day
or two.
You know what?
I have to,
I have to make sure that I'm watching out for that.
So,
you know,
even I get caught in it every second month going down there,
you know?
Yeah.
This isn't an,
Hanzo has just a fucking lines down of killers down there to just take a room of
black belts.
Have you gone to 10 planet at all if you turn down here with Eddie?
No,
but I'd like to,
I'll set it up.
Let me know when you want to go.
He'll help you.
He's actually leg dragged him in the hall.
I met him.
Was He just on his back?
He's got,
he's got a back problem right now.
Oh really?
That probably didn't help it.
No,
no.
He's got a,
he's dealing with some back spasms.
He's a,
he works as guard so much.
It's like you so lower back intensive.
So he's doing a lot of rehab stuff and we were talking about this before the
show,
but that is a big issue with fighters is like back injuries,
one of the most difficult to overcome because so many guys get 'em and then
their,
their skill level deteriorates.
Whereas like if you get a knee injury,
he gets sold a surgery on it.
Like George Saint Pierre came back better than ever.
You know,
the guys can come back from knee surgery.
Conor McGregor better than ever.
Right?
Um,
yeah.
I constantly have to be keeping up with my back maintenance.
Like I had to pull it to a fight because of her neck problem.
So my neck and back at a constant thing that I have to watch and have therapy
down on two,
three times a week.
You know,
what kind of therapy do you do a massage and Osteo all the time.
It doesn't stop for me or else I just like stiffen up and I'm like,
you know,
with the amount of training I'm doing,
but I like to do like a warmup and cool down before every single training
session with different exercises to like activate my muscles and my back
stretching it.
Uh,
um,
he uh,
I do a lot of planks like just like planking exercise that's pretty good for my
back as well.
Um,
that machine you just showed me in the back.
Yeah,
we have one of those that Tristar,
I should probably start using that a lot more than
the things.
Incredible things.
Incredible.
It's so,
it was crazy.
We were talking about,
I was created by this Guy Louie Simmons,
who's this power lifting legend who's like,
I think he's 67 or something crazy like that,
who's just fucking enormous.
Dude's still dead,
lifts some insane amount of weight and he injured his back.
They were going to do surgery,
they wanted a fuses disks and he wouldn't let him.
And he figured out a way to make a machine that active actively decompresses
your spine and strengthens it.
And the same time,
it's very difficult to describe the motion.
So if anybody's interested,
if you have any sort of a back injury,
Google reverse hyper and uh,
I got mine from broke fitness,
but there's a couple of companies that sell them including Westside Barbell,
which is Louie Simmons Company.
Right.
But he invented it.
It amazing thing.
But for fighters,
just a giant tool to strengthen your core and build up your spinal column.
They could see him.
He's like fucking 70 in this picture.
It's enormous dude.
But the,
the maintenance and um,
the uh,
physical therapy and all that stuff.
How do you schedule that in?
Do you have someone who does your schedule as far as like your,
you do everything,
strength and conditioning,
all your stuff?
Yeah.
How do you organize it?
Just over time.
It just like Kinda,
you know,
I've been at Tristar for like seven years now,
so like over time you kind of figure out what to take away,
what to put in on that day and see what works out.
So it's just a gradual progression of learning where things fit in on the,
on certain days.
Do you have a g?
Do You keep a journal?
Like a training journal?
No.
No,
just all in your head now.
When you preparing for a fight,
say if you have a big fight coming up,
like your last fight with Terex caffeine and you're concentrating on a guy who's
a kickboxer do go more kickboxing heavy.
Do you do?
No,
not really.
It's,
I kinda just,
I kind of just go with my gut feeling or what I feel like I want to do at the
period of time.
Um,
I've,
lately I've been doing a lot of Jujitsu.
Um,
I've just been feeling excited about it,
so I followed that excitement.
You know,
sometimes if like,
I really feel like doing a lot of kickboxing,
so I find that my schedule is not completely kickboxing,
but it dominates the week.
Mostly.
You're one of the few guys that's come along in MMA.
You like the new crop guys who didn't have a background in wrestling.
You didn't have a background karate.
You're,
you're just from the beginning.
You started in mixed martial arts.
Yeah,
yeah.
I started at 14,
uh,
Toshido mixed martial arts in Colona and uh,
it was just lucky enough to stumble upon an MMA gym for my first martial arts,
um,
GM.
So that's just how it,
it all came about.
I would guess that was just a blessing.
You know,
you,
you're not the type of guy,
like if I didn't know you,
yeah.
You know,
if I met you,
I was telling you,
listen,
normal,
peaceful dudes.
He was pretty,
you know,
like there's,
she meets certain dudes and they got this cat.
Like you've met Josh Barnett,
you're like,
yeah,
I could see that guy being a fire,
a little fucking intense little,
a little high strung.
Yeah,
like mellow
and like even keeled.
I like to be.
Yeah.
Is that on purpose or is this just your personality naturally?
I think nationally it is,
but then there's the other side too,
right?
Where everyone calls me fucking psychos.
Well,
the,
I people were wondering like,
what the fuck is this dude actually like because of like pull,
pull up that this is fucking the,
the death stare.
The Roy McDonald desk,
dare,
where is this?
Where's this coming from,
man?
Is that,
is that just natural?
Does that,
like this death stare that you have when you fight?
Are you aware of it
zone?
I guess you're not even blinking dude.
Yeah.
Well,
when I was fighting Terakki you,
he,
uh,
I caught him like,
just staring at me when I was coming in and it Kinda made me like,
I don't know what the best way to say it.
Kinda like Alpha male.
Like I was just like,
you're like,
we were fighting for territory,
so he was just like,
you know,
like a couple of dogs staring down at each other before we were about to fight.
I Dunno.
It kinda felt like that
some guys are telling you that,
you know,
boss route and you still avoid eye contact.
I didn't make eye contact.
It doesn't bother me either way.
Like,
I don't think me staring at them,
it's gonna make me win the fight.
Right,
right,
right.
It has nothing to do with that.
I totally believe in skill over any of the psychological battles or,
uh,
you know,
being bigger or smaller.
But I guess it's,
uh,
it just,
it just happens.
It just happens and you just go with it.
The same thing.
Yeah.
You just like,
fuck this.
I'm staring them down.
Yeah.
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna look away and make you make me feel like I'm a
bitch.
That's a weird moment though,
right?
Yeah,
it is awkward I guess.
But when you get into the octagon,
you know,
regardless on,
who you're fighting,
like how important the is.
Do you have like a routine that you go through mentally?
Do you have like a preparation that you go through?
No.
If anything,
I'm just thinking about techniques and my head,
but sometimes I'm not thinking about anything.
I just can't wait to,
they ring that bell
make you wait for so long anyway.
Is that the hardest part?
Is the anticipation not really kinda used to it by now.
Has it become like as you've fought more and more guys higher and higher level,
has it become more and more like a relaxed to you or more normal?
Yeah,
it's normal.
Especially when you're fighting like,
like I've been real busy the last year or two,
so it's every fight now seems like it's just like,
it's,
I remember this feeling.
Yeah,
that's big,
right?
Yeah,
it is.
That's why you see the guy like Dominick Cruz,
it's out for three years.
It makes his fight even more impressive when he just,
yeah,
he talked Mitzi Gawky.
Yeah.
Steamrolled him.
He did do it very well.
Incredible fucking look better than he's ever looked.
When you see a guy like that though,
um,
you know,
you're making a living off of your body.
I mean,
you make a living with your body and your goals are predicated on the health of
your body and you see like got a guy like Dominick Cruz who tore his ACL and
then he tore his hamstring and tore his ACL again.
I mean,
he allowed a lot fucking series of serious fucking injuries and shit almost
three years out.
Does that freak you out when you see shit like that?
Yeah.
That would suck
a,
I guess.
Yeah,
just hope to God that never happens to me.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's,
that's a massive hurdle to overcome.
Props to him for coming back and that guy.
But he's good too.
He's very good.
He's,
he's like the
far cetera when it comes to footwork and movement.
When you see a guy like that who runs into such a massive hurdle,
like a three year absence from the sport like that,
does that make you change your preparation any way or be a little bit more
cautious or be a little bit more diligent about strength and conditioning or
rehab
didn't like that?
No.
Like other people's lives don't really influence mine.
I'm just,
I just,
uh,
I feel like I go with the flow a lot,
you know,
if,
uh,
you know,
if I see something that movie beneficial to me,
then I'll do it.
Or if I'm,
I want to go a certain direction and my martial arts career,
then I'm going to go there.
I don't care if it didn't work out so well for that guy,
I'm going to go down that path.
You know,
I follow my instincts and my excitement.
It's such a fascinating way to pursue a goal in life,
you know,
to pursue a goal of becoming a champion,
mixed martial arts fighter.
There's so few people that you can kind of like figure out how to do it from.
Maybe it's like best that you have this mentality.
Just figure out yourself.
You can't fear,
you can't let fear into your life,
you know,
or else it's just going to take over and you know,
just because this guy hurt his knee and was out for three years,
it shouldn't stop me from going and fighting for what I want.
Right.
Maybe you could be,
you could take some precautions but,
and do things a little bit smarter.
But
no.
When you say things like you can't let fear into your life or into your mind,
do you actively try to block that out?
Is this
something that you work on?
Yeah,
I would say so.
Yeah.
It's like,
I guess the best example is,
is just going into a fight.
Like you see some guys are terrified and it works for them,
like George.
Right,
right,
right.
But I'm not scared at all.
Like,
I'm nervous.
I definitely have nerves.
I'm not going to lie about that,
you know,
and the anticipation of it.
And I think it's natural to just,
your body just knows what it's about to go do.
But I,
I'm not going to fear what I'm about to do.
I'm going to take it head on and I'm going to conquer it.
So when George would fight,
he would have like some serious nerves.
Yeah.
He's terrified.
So buddy,
what's crazy when you think he's the best welterweight ever?
Yeah.
It's crazy.
Like all week before his fight,
he just won't stop talking about how scared he is real.
It's just,
it's really funny actually.
But why does he dwell on it?
I don't know.
It's just,
it's just how he prepares for fights.
And it's interesting.
I don't,
I don't relate to it at all.
He's a fascinating guy because he'll tell everyone what his fears are,
tell everyone what his weaknesses are.
It's almost like he's setting himself up to half to overcome those things.
Yeah,
I,
yeah.
I don't know why he does that
cause he performed so well.
I mean he has all,
it's like traditionally like if you would tell someone like what's the best
thing to concentrate on concert on positive things,
focusing on the positive,
but then you look at George and the achievements that he's been able to,
to make and you know,
he's the greatest welterweight of all time.
Yeah.
Andy.
Andy has it that much more impressive that he,
you know,
he has all these fears and then he overcomes them.
He forces himself to push through that.
Anyway.
What's interesting,
well,
what's interesting with George is just a couple different versions of George
does.
It's like the play it safe.
George does it try to,
when George and then there's a Georgia fought Bj Penn that was legitimately
fucking pissed off like,
you know what I mean?
Like when he fought Matt Serra the second time.
Yeah,
legitimately pissed off.
But I think like Matt Serra as a person didn't bother him as much.
Bj Did.
Bj got under his skin.
Like,
I remember like when Bj was cell telling them that he was going to be fighting
to the death and you know,
you could see George is like,
you mother fucker talking all this crazy shit.
Like,
you know,
calling him,
I can't help it.
Some of that stuff like bug you.
Right.
Yeah.
But it seemed like that was like one of his most impressive performances.
Like he wasn't just trying to win that fight.
He was trying to beat the fuck outta be saying.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
It was like a different thing.
Yeah.
But it also has to do,
I think with the skill level of your opponent.
Um,
Eh,
and the style of fight that the way the fights going,
you know,
I don't think Georgia intentionally tries to play it safe.
He's constantly fighting the best guy in the world for 10 years in a row.
Cause he's the champ,
right?
So it's the guy,
the next guy at his best peaking for this,
the moment,
the most important moment in his martial arts career.
He's got to fight that guy for 10 years or however long he held that belt in a
row.
People don't really take that into equation.
You know?
He's always got to be the best in the world,
you know?
Yeah.
People always say that like,
oh,
he hasn't finished anybody.
Look,
look at the fucking people.
He's fighting it
and not just that they're at their best.
They're not just training for another fight is the moment.
Yeah.
So it's quite impressive and I think people forget about that sometimes
it is.
And you know what is,
what was equally impressive was that he had the,
the awareness to step away.
Just say,
you know what,
I just need to take a break.
Yeah.
You know,
and there's been talk about him returning and I know he's starting to train
again and he's training and enjoying it and he's not making any decisions.
But I appreciate the fact that with all the money that's on the line,
all the money that he could potentially be earning all the pressure to get him
to fight again,
that he had the presence of mind to go,
you know,
on,
let me just step back.
Yeah.
I think it's just part of knowing yourself and I think it's important.
Like the guy has no life.
If you got,
if you seeing how this guy trains,
you'd be blown away.
I'd never met anyone who trains that are really,
yeah.
He's like,
he's got OCD.
So it's like everything has to be perfect.
And this training is like,
he can't miss a day,
even if he's exhausted or you know,
he's feeling like shit.
Like the guy's just a workhorse is what it takes.
Right.
It's for some guys,
for me,
not so much.
No.
I tried doing that and it just didn't work for me.
That's interesting.
Yeah.
So you,
you have your own protocol like you just saw.
Yeah,
I go with how I'm feeling.
I think after Metamorris,
uh,
you know,
I've been here for a couple of days now and I could have went training,
but I felt like crap,
I'm solar,
my arm,
see as though I'm chilling.
And then tomorrow I'll probably,
I'll go train cause there'll be,
I'll be into it,
you know,
and then
I'll be excited to train,
you know,
and I'll get the most out of that training session.
I'll be aware,
I'll be listening to the guys around me and I'll be,
and I'll be,
I'll take as much as I can out of that training session and feel good about it.
And for me personally,
I feel like my skills increase more that way when I go to the gym,
like,
like a strict two d two a days,
you know,
every single day my body breaks down and I'm at the training session on my,
uh,
I don't care about what anyone says,
you know,
I'm just getting through it rather than taking part in it.
You know,
I've had conversations with many trainers about this and one of the things that
a lot of people were in agreement,
um,
is that there is an unrealistic expectation about what your body can go through
that may be based on a lot of guys who use drugs.
A lot of guys who use performance enhancing drugs like this guys who will tell
you their training three times a day,
seven days a week,
and if you're doing that,
if they aren't doing that,
they have to be taken some shit.
I have no idea how anyone could,
like my body
is dying,
you know,
after a half a week at training once a day,
I don't know how these guys do that,
man.
It's,
it blows my mind.
I just,
I just stay away from it.
Well,
the demands of MMA are so different than any other sport because you're
essentially learning three major sports.
You know,
you're learning,
striking,
you'll learn and kickboxing,
you learning wrestling and you're learning Jujitsu.
I mean there's three
of them together and you're incorporating them with strategy and different
positions.
That's fucking crazy combinations.
I look at John Jones.
He can,
yeah.
He so he's like an artist though thing,
you know?
Yes.
Yeah.
Intertwining them too is it's like an art of its own.
It's such a all encompassing sort of a competition,
which is why a guy like George with OCD,
a guy who just is training constantly and relentlessly is white cells in the US
because he can ramp it up to a point where a lot of people just can't keep up
with them.
It works for him.
Yeah.
Did you try,
when you first start came to Tristar seven years ago,
you were a guy who,
I mean how old he now 2025.
So you were fucking God damn.
Day 18 you were 18 when he came to Tristar and so you were doing well,
you were,
you know,
you were starting to,
uh,
to fight and you're starting to excel and your techniques,
you just realized I need to go to where the best gym in the country is.
I had come down there to visit,
uh,
when I wasn't fighting or you know,
just to get a weekend of training with the guys and just see what another Jim
was like cause I've only been at one gym train with those people.
Right.
So I wanted to explore martial arts a little bit and uh,
the amount of talent there and the technical approach there,
I felt that I couldn't really excel with that.
Yeah.
For Rasa Hobby,
I was hoping that he was going to be able to make it in here but he's got some
family obligations.
Just had a daughter.
I love that dude.
Yeah.
Fascinating guy.
And one of the best coaches like he's got,
the one thing that drives me crazy is when I listened to coaches in between
rounds and they just say nonsense.
Like you got to get after him.
He got to knock them out.
Like get out of there one,
one,
a BJ's fights.
There was like,
you got to get them Bj do at Hilo style or something.
Like they were saying like some crazy shit.
I was like,
does he have anybody in there that can give him some fucking technical advice?
Yeah,
that's crazy.
Tell him what is going wrong.
Step off to the left.
You know it do change levels.
Do something you gotta you gotta give him some,
I understand that approach in some situations.
If the guy's just sleeping and he's just not willing to work,
you got to wake him up.
But for me,
I need someone to give me the technical advice cause I'm in there fighting,
trying to figure this puzzle out.
You know,
and,
and fraudsters and John,
Donna her do a really excellent job with giving me those,
those pieces of the puzzle.
Right?
Yeah.
Donna,
hers a another guy and unheralded brilliant guy.
Love talking to that guy.
Yeah,
he's a smart guy.
He was a guy that I want,
I'm talking to,
I worked out with George once we worked out on spinning back kick technique.
I seen that doing it through Donna her because don hurt came to me and he said
he's was like,
I need to find someone who,
uh,
has a in,
you know,
we
wind up talking about spinning back kick technique and then I worked out with
George,
but you talked to John and he's just this weird quiet encyclopedia of
information when it comes to martial arts.
He's got a very,
yeah,
it's,
yeah.
He's an incredible guy.
He's a brilliant dude.
Yeah.
Really.
Unheralded I don't think people in the business understand.
Yeah.
He's not into it for the media or the attention at all.
He's just,
he's so,
he has such a deep passion for martial arts and finding out how to beat another
person.
It's just genius.
I heard a skill level on the mat and is incredible too.
Yeah.
The,
and the way he teaches to like things he's coming up with just so cutting edge
wouldn't mind.
That's,
that's a big part of success in MMA,
isn't it?
Surrounding herself with great training partners and having minds like that.
Coaches,
yeah.
You need for a coach,
you need someone just as dedicated on the other side of the fence as you are
doing the physical work.
You know,
cause you know you need,
you need that skill.
You need to be able to,
to take what,
take the skill from them and put it into your physical training.
Right?
Yeah.
That's what Duane Ludwig brought to team Alpha male.
And you see like what a massive impact.
That's how,
yeah.
Cause he's just as crazy about coaching as those guys are about fighting.
I mean,
if you ever meet Dwayne,
he's got just notebooks and fucking stacks of shit that he's,
you know,
into and he's constantly revising his routine,
the routines and the drills that he runs guys through and sizing things up.
Like when Tj Dillashaw beat Hanan Barao I had lunch with Ludwig that day.
Uh,
and Dwayne,
Dwayne,
you ever talked to Dwayne?
He's a maniac.
I could talk to him.
He was talking a million miles.
Now it's just kind of doing a little one.
He's like one of those dudes and he was like,
what can I do?
He's got to step off to the left.
You got to make sure that when when brow a taxi,
a taxi over committed see stays flat foot.
He does this with Tj is going to do,
is going to do a lot of things and it's just this red line and constantly and he
essentially blueprinted exactly what was going to happen in the fight.
He explained to me exactly what's going to happen in the fight and Tj and him.
How such a close relationship that it was just one of those situations where the
Co,
the right coach met the right student and the student is a sponge and he just
listens to everything Dwayne says.
You know what's really funny about it is we were talking about this during one
of the fight podcasts is that,
you know,
who doesn't fight the way Duane teachers,
Dwayne,
he never fall like that.
He's not like captain footwork,
no precision puncher,
precision puncher,
precision kicker,
excellent Moy Tai,
but he wasn't that like crazy footwork dude.
Too much.
It's weird,
but he teaches TJ and it's perfect.
It's almost like do as I say,
not as I do,
or maybe his body didn't work that way,
or maybe he didn't need to or he had a different approach.
Right.
But he's doing good work out there.
Yeah,
he really is.
I'm amazed.
I mean,
it's one of the things that's most exciting to me about MMA is the differences
in approach as far as like different coaches and the results because nobody
really knows exactly what the right way to do it is.
And it's different for you.
You said as it is for George,
it's probably different for Tj than it is for like Joseph Benevidez.
Like everybody has their own approach and it's,
it's just a matter of figuring it all out and working it all out.
And there's so many variables.
It's just an endlessly fascinating to me.
It is.
Yeah.
It's,
it's crazy.
There's so many new guys too.
It's so exciting right now.
Yeah.
That meant a new talent coming out and,
and,
and the new,
uh,
like you look at Ronda Rousey,
Conor Mcgregor,
these guys are so different from what we've seen like five years ago.
It's great.
No,
no one was using judo throw.
It was like Rhonda is no one's crazy or hectoring my,
yeah,
act.
It has very little Lombard versus Jake shields was a judo exhibition.
Yeah.
That was pretty crazy.
That was a dominant name fight.
And he's,
he's a motherfucker now when you see a guy like Lombard and you see a fight like
that with Jake shields,
does that get you excited about fighting him?
Yeah.
I can tell.
He's a,
he's going to be fun to fight for sure.
I'm excitable.
Fighting him.
And you were excited about fight and Tyron Woodley,
who's a another powerful explosive guy.
Powerful guy.
You know,
I felt like,
uh,
my technique had overcome,
you know,
his physical,
uh,
you know,
obviously you look at me and he look at him,
he's physically superior,
you know,
like he's an athlete.
Like just cut it out of stone.
And I felt like it was exciting for me to see,
you know,
all the skill that I've skill work I've done over the years to overcome a
bigger,
stronger,
faster opponent.
You know,
cause I was never that guy.
I,
I'm athletic guy,
but when I started martial arts,
I was a,
I was a little Puke,
you know,
I got beat up by bigger kids are,
so it's kind of,
it was a cool thing for me,
especially being in Vancouver to fight a guy like that and uh,
use my skill to like,
you know,
solve this puzzle of the bigger,
faster,
stronger guy.
No,
that was a beautiful fine.
It was a beautiful fight that was a fight there.
You really kind of shut him down,
you know,
in a weird way.
Like he didn't,
he didn't really didn't have an answer.
I didn't know what to do.
Yeah,
he was,
he was waiting for a certain certain thing.
Yeah.
And I also love how you use that high elbow to block the right hand.
That's a,
that's,
that's interesting.
And that's a little use technique is that for us?
Yep.
Um,
the Philly show was used in the olden days when gloves were around,
um,
for,
uh,
blocking headshots,
um,
because the bigger gloves now in,
and you can just go like this and right.
You put your hands up.
But now with our gloves or no gloves,
this doesn't really stop anything.
It still hurts like hell.
Your temple is exposed a lot.
Your,
your jaw line back here is exposed a lot of these little a your fist can fit
through these little spaces now because there's not a huge pillow,
a huge pillar but a bigger pillar to absorb that,
that impact.
So they,
they started using the Phillies show and using elbows and forearms and,
and your,
your tricep to,
to,
to fill in those holes against uh,
you know,
just bare knuckle.
So I,
I felt that it would be useful to me.
Yeah.
It's interesting when you go back and you look at like old school boxing matches
when they had the little tiny gloves I go look at someone like the Jack Dempsey
fights.
Like they were,
they were fighting with almost like a little bag gloves.
Yeah they just had like leather all over their hands.
Yeah.
But which is very similar to MMA gloves.
Yes,
I know.
What do you think about no gloves?
I like it.
Do you like that better?
Yeah,
I think about that all the time.
Cause I'm like,
why is it okay to Shin kick a guy in the head?
Why is it okay to Nia guy,
the head or elbow,
but you have to protect your knuckles.
Like is that some leftover hold out stuff from box and it could be the idea that
you need pants.
Yeah.
And maybe just for the media to write,
we need to have rounds.
We need to have uh,
rules and,
and,
and gloves and some kind of protection so that the mainstream media can accept
it as a sport.
But yeah,
the raw UFC first,
the first fights,
you know,
that's,
that was the real deal.
But it seems contradictory to me because how come you like,
like a Edson Barboza Terry Adam Lowry wheel kicks him in the head and some of
his heel.
I mean,
that is the hardest part of your body.
You're walking around on it all the time.
You could take your heel and walk up to a wall and dump the wall.
Yeah.
Anybody could do that.
Well,
you could take a little kid and I get stomped the wall,
take a little kid and tell him to go punch the wall.
Yeah.
It'll hurt.
Like it hurts everybody.
Like you can't do it.
Yeah.
And it seems to me that it's very unrealistic to wrap up the hands,
tape up the risks because that's an issue as well.
The,
the,
the risks move,
you know,
and you have this unrealistic expectation of how you could just sort of tee off
on people and,
and brawl with them.
Whereas if it was just bare knuckle,
you'd be forced to be much more precise with your punches and be much more
realistic in the,
in the impact of them.
I think it,
I think our gloves to aren't helpful for the situation.
I think the UFC loaves could get a little bit better.
In what way?
Um,
they're kind of like round and so they make your hand open up.
Uh,
right.
You're always talking about Ipos.
The glove is a big reason for right,
in my opinion.
Yeah.
Um,
have you tried to bell tore gloves?
No,
the bell time I tried the old pride gloves.
They were awesome.
You like those better?
Yeah,
we used to have those laying around here somewhere.
I would probably have in the back,
the old pride gloves have more of a curve to them and if you've watched the old
price does make a fist and keep your fist and very rare that you saw I pokes,
you know,
they um,
Bella tour is using some Everlast gloves that do two things.
One,
it curves the fist more,
keeps the fist closed more.
And another thing is it reinforces the,
uh,
the metacarpal.
Okay.
Reinforce.
It's more padding in here where it's preventing handbrakes.
Right.
Which it makes it thicker,
which makes it harder to choke people,
which probably not good.
I think like especially for Jujitsu and grappling,
I think it would definitely benefit people if there was no gloves.
Okay.
Yeah.
It might even stop the,
I polks more if there was no gloves because your hand wouldn't automatically
open up.
Yup.
I agree with that.
Yeah.
I don't know if people are willing to,
I don't think so.
Not,
not,
not in the mainstream media and no,
I don't think so.
But how crazy is that though?
Cause you could smash it.
You get on top of a guy and you could literally smash his eyeball open with your
elbow.
Yeah.
It's just like,
I think it's people's predisposition.
Like they're,
they're,
you know,
they need to see that glove,
whatever.
Even though every other part of your body that's used as a weapon in the MMA
world is the protective Ashlyn is harder.
Shins and knees,
you know,
I mean like God,
you know?
Yeah.
Elbows are a big,
you know,
they cut you.
Yeah.
Do you think that elbows,
she,
there's another argument that elbow shouldn't be allowed,
like the Strikeforce rules.
They have to,
they have to be alone because they're effective.
Yeah.
What about,
I mean,
I think headbutts and knees on the ground need to be involved to really,
yeah,
I would like to see that.
Yeah.
Right.
Like welcome.
You can punch a guy in the head,
but you can like smash them with your head like it is a legitimate weapon would
change with knees on the ground to the head and head butts.
It would change the dynamic of ground fighting.
What about soccer kicks?
Yeah,
that too.
But what about soccer kicks being a problem?
Because guys get pinned up against the cage.
That's the only argument that I've ever heard.
That makes a lot of sense to me that they shouldn't be legal because you can get
your head stuck.
Yeah.
But the fight would be over pretty quick.
So the idea is just don't get stuck.
Yeah.
Don't get there.
Pay The price.
I wonder if any organization could ever,
if anybody would do it,
it would be Japan.
You know,
Japan would take it to who's good one.
Fcs got some good rules.
Yeah.
Well they have a weird rule where they allow you,
like they say open fight or something like that where they allow the referee's
discretion.
They have to time it or something.
Yeah.
That's weird.
And there's been to where it got awkward.
Yeah.
I don't know about all that.
That's a bit weird.
I don't know about the referee deciding cause what have you get an idiot
referee,
you know?
That does happen.
A lot of those,
there's some times where guys are battling for position and it's like a very
important transition in a fight and the referee will like be like yelling at
them.
Like,
come on guys,
you gotta work,
you gotta work.
Like what are you watching?
You not watching a fight.
These guys are fighting and in my opinion,
like as long as guys aren't actively stalling,
as long as they really are trying to get to a better position where you're
watching is an important part of grappling.
That's why I'm against standups.
Yeah,
me too.
Good.
That's awesome.
Yeah,
I think it's like just play out.
Yeah.
That's where the note,
that's where the no,
no rounds and no time of them.
It also plays a big part in a fight to,
yeah,
it should,
but you know,
I,
I kind of understand the idea of rounds is that it makes it more exciting and
guys get to recover in between rounds.
They don't seem so exhausted,
but the,
if you're going to have rounds that I'm really against standups.
Yeah.
If a guy could take you down to molest you for five rounds and just hold you in
place and,
and beat on you,
Ben and her in style.
That's life.
Yeah.
You got to learn how to deal with that.
You gotta yeah.
The tech technical skill to be able to get out of that situation.
Yeah.
And ask her,
and I was Kinda bummed out when he signed with one fc because I was like,
I want to see what that guy couldn't do in the UFC against elite guys.
Like when he fought Douglas Lema in uh,
in Beltour.
I was like,
Holy Shit.
Like he could do that to that guy.
Like Lima's a bad mother fucker and he's pretty good fucking rag doll and I'm
going to ask her is so goddamn good at wrestling.
Yeah.
You know,
he's good.
It's important to have guys like that around.
Yeah.
You know it,
I think maybe,
maybe UFC is worried about him beating the exciting guys and then having a
boring guy around because no one likes to watch him.
Maybe I do.
It's a fan friendly.
Yes.
But who knows if he would,
you know,
you've got to take a cheek setting part.
Yeah.
My thought on it,
I'm a purist in my thought on it is you don't know who the best in the world is
until you take the guys who are the most dangerous or in his case,
the most problematic.
And you got to pick them up against each other.
And unless you do,
it's not legit.
Yeah.
It'd be nice to see him in the EOC to see if he is,
you know,
a top contender for real.
Yeah.
I mean,
or you put them in there with a guy like you who could shut them down and you
say,
oh,
okay,
well here's his issue.
You know,
you know,
we've seen it time and time again.
We just saw with Eddie Alvarez,
Eddie Alvarez,
who look great and Beltour Donald Cerrone just picks his leg apart and you go,
oh,
okay,
well here's this is the new level.
You hit the next level.
Yeah.
You see?
You see a guy's from other organizations that come in,
they start to see,
maybe they're not so invincible in,
we'll look at Hector Lombard when,
when he was fighting a one 85 in Beltour,
he was rushing.
People came over to the UFC.
Tim Boetsch beats him and you know,
10 bucks is a very good fighter.
No,
no doubt about it.
But what the issue was is Bosch is a natural two oh five cuts down to one 85 and
lombards and one 70 who's a little blown up to be one 85 and the skill level and
the toughness of Boesch allowed him to beat him.
And that's,
you know,
everybody was saying like Walmart's going to come over and smash everybody and
he's looks really good now at one 70 but that's,
that's important.
You got to see that play out.
Yeah.
And if it doesn't play out,
I feel like,
I feel like I got robbed.
Like I feel,
I really do.
Like when astron sign with one FC,
I remember reading it online.
I was like,
what that fun.
You get a fight over there.
I was upset.
I mean maybe he maybe in a year or two years the talent level of one FC will
rise to the occasion or you know,
maybe he'll go over to bell a tour,
who,
who the fuck knows may or maybe come back rather the ballots or who the fuck
knows,
you know now the cokers there and Bjorn has gone,
you know,
who knows.
Maybe that was the issue that the reason why he left and maybe
it'd be nice to see him in the EOC.
I,
it'd be nice to see another organization really fucking step up and be like,
pride was to like be like the other competition would be good for the fighters.
Good for everybody.
Right.
And it's good for everybody in weight classes too.
Like a weight class like yours welterweight.
I mean you got a fucking murderers row at welterweight and that's important and
that's why you know,
all these new guys are coming up and that they're at a very high level and like
it seems like whenever you have a really super ultra competitive weight class,
it's all these people start rising to the occasion and you see better
performances from all of them.
Yeah,
yeah.
The welterweight division.
It's crazy,
man.
It's like so unstable.
You never know who's going to come out on top.
It's like a pressure cooker.
But I think,
I think it,
I think I'm going to,
you know,
I'm coming up right now and I think I might be able to dominate the division
soon.
Well you're definitely getting better.
You know,
that's one of the things getting in the opportunity.
I'm fighting for the title next,
so I guess we'll see.
Yeah,
you're fighting against,
[inaudible] was a big eye opener for a lot of people cause saffron and is known
as a standup guy and you set traps for him,
man.
You know,
that was a,
that was a really interesting fight.
You know,
there's small details going on in that.
Yeah.
That was a big victory.
You know,
catching him like that and stopping him like that.
That was a big victory.
The Damien Maia fight was a big victory.
That was probably my favorite fight.
Yeah,
because he got you down that first round when he's most dangerous,
both dry and you know,
it got you down,
be defended perfectly,
you know,
and then he's a tough guy and not a lot of people recognize him in the
welterweight division right now.
We so strong,
so strong at texts.
Crazy and getting down to one 70 you see him very tactical,
but also like physically strong,
like the Rick story fight.
Yeah.
You know,
no one's ever taken story down like that and he's crushed.
It crushes John Fitch.
No one ran through Fitch like that at the time.
He,
John Fitch,
Fitch.
I know,
right?
Yeah,
it's true.
I mean that's what fits would do to guys out grapple them and beat them down.
Yeah.
That's another issue that I wanted to bring up his weight cutting.
That's that sort of highlights.
Why like weight cutting?
Fuck.
It's,
it's unfortunate,
but it's reality.
How much do you cut?
Um,
well right now about 200 Jesus Christ sign.
Yeah.
But I'm not like jacked Tall Guy Hotel six two,
six one six,
six foot.
And I added an inch too for some reason that was about,
so it's not too hard for me actually.
I just diet.
So two months normally naturally weigh 200 pounds.
And then the week of the fight,
how much do you weigh?
Uh,
like before the fight I'll be 82 one a two.
So you lose somehow or another 18 pounds along the way.
And how are you doing that?
Is Diet man healthy eating,
but you're not a lot of extra stuff.
I would never imagine that.
I am not like I'm not ripped all year round.
I'm only,
I'm only really kite when I'm cutting weight from my fight.
I have a lot of extra excess weight,
I guess water weight or whatever you want to call it.
Do you watch your diet all year round or when you don't have a fight you fuck
her off?
Pretty much.
I like to eat kind of healthy.
But yeah,
I definitely go off.
Yeah.
What do you think about guys who,
well,
you're pretty extreme weight cutter then.
I mean that's,
that's not really though,
cause it's not hard for me.
No,
no,
it's,
it's really not.
Like if you asked my coaches,
like I'm just cruising,
well one 82 the week of is not bad,
you know?
Yeah.
That's it down there 12 he comfortable and then it's just like I don't eat too
much and you know,
I managed my water levels properly and I am exercising and I have a good system.
It works for me.
That is another issue though.
That goes along with training for a fight,
the issue of dehydrating yourself essentially and getting down to 170 pounds for
a brief amount of time.
And then when you step into the octagon,
what do you weigh and pull on a five so not bad.
So you're not straining yourself too much.
You don't deplete your body too much.
I feel good.
I'm a lot of the times I feel like I could fight when I,
when I would get on the scale.
Really.
Yeah.
I really don't feel bad at all.
That's nice to hear because there are some guys that push it so far.
Yeah,
I've had that in the past,
like,
well I just do like,
I just cut water,
but now I die at the white off naturally and I feel great.
So it was just a matter of like being a bit more disciplined in your camp.
Yeah.
Nutrition's a big part of it and yeah,
I use,
um,
do you know George Lockhart is?
No.
Uh,
he's a nutritionist,
a x fighter and uh,
yeah,
he's got a good system.
Um,
I think his website,
a fitness VT,
so he's one of those dolce type dudes.
He,
I think he's a bit different than dolce.
In what way?
There's a lot of marketing machine.
No,
and I think he's just a little more natural,
a little more natural.
Xd is trying to say,
dude,
I dunno.
I've just heard things
you're talking about like diuretics.
I don't know what they're doing over there,
but uh,
it's not for me.
Well that was Bj's accusation.
Yeah,
the diuretics thing.
Yeah.
I Dunno.
I don't,
I don't like to play with any of that.
I like to keep it natural and I have a healthy
nutrient rich body,
you know,
let my skill did the work for me.
Well apparently you can use diuretics that are natural though.
Or a vitamin C in high doses is apparently a natural diuretic.
That's what a,
they say dolce uses.
Okay.
One of the things that he does,
I have no idea what a system is.
I don't know either,
but a lot of guys have been popped for diuretics in the past and none adult
chairs guys have.
Okay.
So I don't know if Woody's,
do you mean there's,
there's,
it's like performance enhancing drugs are performance enhancing substances.
It's,
it's a fun,
such a strange thing because there are nutrients that you can isolate in levels
that you would normally never get in food.
You know,
you can take nutrients and I that are healthy and normal,
but you extract them from food,
you take them in pill form and they can without a doubt improve your
performance.
Okay.
But those are illegal because they're essentially food based supplements,
vitamins and nutrients,
vitamins,
nutrients,
not natural thing,
concepts,
mushrooms,
things along those lines.
Optum,
it allows you,
the Chinese Olympic team used it and we actually have some here.
I'll,
I'll give you something before it's totally safe.
It's called shroom tech.
You've ever heard of shroom tech sport.
It allows your body to better utilize oxygen.
It actually came from high altitude hurting populations had found that their
cows were eating these mushrooms that were growing and they were more active.
And so that was a initially how it was discovered.
They actually grow it on caterpillars.
That's really kind of fucking freaky.
Yeah.
But so these,
this is a natural,
natural,
natural nutrition.
Exactly.
Nutrients and things that,
you know,
it's,
this isn't like EPL or something.
Exactly.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
If it is natural and you know,
it's,
I think that's,
that should be allowed,
right?
Yeah.
But then you get things like creatine,
which was also behind the natural,
but you're taking it in forms where you would never get it from meat beneficial
to a fighter though.
15 no,
there's been studies,
there's been studies that say the creatine improves.
So physical strength,
but there's also been studies that show it makes you retain water,
which is one of the last things that a fighter would want,
especially when you were about to cut weight.
I don't really take too many supplements that are not really educated are all
right too much.
I take the protein and like bcas
and stuff.
What kind of protein do you use?
Do use plant based or a,
yeah,
he's Vega and that's good stuff.
Definitely in the past.
Yeah.
Dudes way,
way approaching it wrong.
No,
no,
just mostly plant based.
Yeah,
I'm,
and you know what,
I don't do it all the time.
I just,
I kinda use it once in a while.
So this should probably use more supplements.
I think eating good really helps me a lot.
I drink a lot of water.
Do you drink your,
you're,
you have a coffee?
Their coffee.
I like coffee.
Do you fuck around with that?
Like the week of the fights?
You know,
it doesn't seem to mess with you.
It doesn't bother me.
Yeah.
Tito Ortiz used to say that coffee fucks with your cardio,
but I've never heard that before.
The fact of her helps.
I haven't had a problem with it.
I just have a coffee a day usually.
What does this nutrition guy again,
what's his name?
George Lockhart.
Lockhart.
And does he propose or prescribed meals for you?
Does he like,
he'll have like a meal plan and stuff and like,
um,
he'll help balance it for your work schedule.
Like,
uh,
he,
he does it for like regular people and then like,
you know,
athletes and fighters and stuff.
So you can punch in like your workout schedule.
Uh,
it's detailed,
like how much you walking that day,
how much you're sitting down,
how much you're sleeping.
Um,
all kinds of stuff like that.
And uh,
how much body fat you are,
how tall you are,
what your goals are.
So it's a whole like system he has in place.
So he's very specific.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
This guy knows his stuff.
If you ever talk to them,
it's just like,
like 90% of the things just go right over your head cause he just like,
he's using words that you've never heard of and he's talking fast and he's a
smart guy.
He's one of those dudes you have to ask him like three times the same question
to like kind of feel a little bit like,
you know what he's talking about.
So do you um,
just get a plan from him or does he actually cut,
make the meals for just like the pine.
So you do all the preparation,
everything yourself,
all your own shopping,
stuff like that.
You Cook for yourself,
all that child?
Yeah.
Oh Wow.
And when it comes to PR portions,
do you measure them out?
Yeah,
I,
I've kind of like figured it out now.
Like just kind of general size.
But when I first started,
yeah,
it was like wait and stuff.
Now what about like green leafy vegetables,
things along those lines to see if it wasn't strong on that?
Yeah,
yeah,
for sure.
All types of different vegetables.
It's mostly vegetables.
I guess.
And what,
what is what source of protein?
There's nuts for like snacks and stuff and then,
you know,
chicken breasts,
certain fish like salmon,
um,
flaming,
you know,
um,
pork tenderloin.
There's a few different ones.
So essentially mostly low fat type stuff.
Yeah.
And do you get your fats from like avocado or coconut oil or avocado oil?
Coconut oil is another one.
There's the nuts,
again,
almonds and stuff,
walnuts.
That's very interesting to me as well that this is something that people
realizing within the last few decade or so that like healthy fats or just as
important as nutrients is a very important part of your diet.
A lot of energy concern,
right?
If you take that stuff out,
your brain's fucking dries up.
When I've,
I've tried like taking fats out of my diet like way back in the day after I
experimented with different diets and one of the things that I've found is I got
stupid,
like my brain wasn't working as well.
Like I could feel the difference.
Yeah.
You need to like oil your brain.
I don't know what the exact mechanism is,
but as flaxseed oil to fish oils,
stuff like that.
And take tablet fish oil or do you like us tablespoons?
Like liquid?
Yeah.
The liquid stuff's a little bit easier to digest.
You don't have to deal with that.
Um,
the gelatin that comes from the outside,
which is essentially just the animal hooves and shit like that.
They turn into,
I take vitamins,
Gel capsules and vitamins.
I don't,
I haven't had a problem with.
And does this Guy George C measure all this stuff out for you as well?
And um,
yeah,
it's,
it's all like portion dote on the site for you.
Do you get blood work done?
Um,
I haven't,
I,
I've,
uh,
I've got prescription to like measure like all,
like my nutrient levels and I've just been too lazy to go get it done.
That's ridiculous though.
Your professional bio at the highest level of the game and I'm,
I'm an idiot.
No,
I don't know.
It's just,
I just,
I'm a procrastinator with it because,
you know,
one day I'll feel like crappy and I'll be talking to my osteopath and it'd be
like,
go get these blood work done,
see what your deficiencies are.
So we'll get a prescription and I'll never go do it.
I'm scared of needles.
It's a big thing.
Get the fuck Outta here.
I pass out.
I'm not joking.
It's not scared to fight in a cage.
I passed.
Don't many times doing like ivs or stuff like that.
Yeah,
man,
I hate it.
I sold like when you're rehydrating like when they give you an ivy,
you pass out.
Yeah.
Faint.
Then I wake up and everyone's looking at it.
I almost attacked for us and a couple of guys because I've woken up and didn't
know where it was and I was just like,
wow,
that's hilarious.
Yeah.
It sucks.
Date this girl who couldn't even watch someone get a needle in a movie,
she would black out.
Yeah.
If I think about it too hard,
then I'll like get like,
see my stomach will like,
that's so weird.
Yeah.
But that's sort of a logical,
I don't understand what that is.
And it only happened like it only started happening like four or five years ago.
We were like blood like cause you have to get blood work done for the fights
right past like your HIV and all that stuff.
And before I would just be like,
yeah,
and it's done.
Walk away now.
Then all of a sudden out of nowhere,
every I see a needle
coming my way,
I go,
my fee,
my face will get white and for no reason that's so strange.
So I have to like get on my phone like this,
I have to lay down like it's a whole person look away and distract myself.
Wow.
Even talking about right now,
I like get like,
that's so strange.
I mean it was,
it would make more sense.
It was something you always had.
Yeah.
It's so weird.
Like my ex girlfriend,
her dad had it and she said that her dad one time,
um,
her brother got like a severe sunburn and the had blisters all over and the Dad
saw it and the dad fainted.
And what's crazy is it dad was a fucking doctor.
He was,
I was,
uh,
he was,
he was a dentist.
So tell me how the fuck is this guy like me?
Obviously it must deal with some fucked up shit and gory things in
dentistry too.
Yeah.
Weird.
Well,
he,
I guess he was okay with needles,
but he would see certain things like he saw his son with blisters,
just like
blisters because you know,
like from the,
from the sun,
from the sunburn.
And he apparently had a really bad sunburn.
Yes.
She was like,
it's weird.
It's fucking weird,
right?
Yeah.
It's in her family I guess.
But it's weird that you acquired it.
That's very nowhere.
It was just like one,
it was,
I was doing blood work for a fight and I was at the hospital and I was just like
an everyday and then I passed out and ever since that it happens.
So I have to be really careful.
That's fucking weird,
dude.
Yeah.
If you've talked to a psychologist about that,
no,
no.
Probably never.
Well,
I would want to know if there's like a coping mechanism for that.
Yeah,
I,
I'll probably just overcome it.
Maybe now,
maybe now you'd be thinking about this conversation we're going to be bringing
in
sports psychology is a very interesting thing to me and I've actually thought
about using a sports psychologist for standup for standup company because I'm
like,
I don't think anybody's ever done that before.
Right.
I bet.
Because a lot of camps incorporate sports psychologist is a heavy part of their
regimen and like Ryan Parsons who uh,
you know,
he trains,
uh,
Dennis Bermudez and he handles a impact.
Comments,
a lot of good guys and he's big on that.
Yeah.
And uh,
I've always been fascinated by sports.
I'm not,
I've never actually sat now with a psychology.
I've gone over my own brain either vi,
I don't know what they would talk about.
Like what would,
what would they tell me?
I don't know to do differently for you.
They probably watched that video you staring and they'd be like,
they good,
good,
good.
Whatever that is,
that place maybe to help you get to that zone,
right?
Yeah.
Well,
that's what I would wonder is for some guys it becomes necessary after a loss
because after a loss,
um,
you know,
there,
there are people that have,
I guess the best way to describe it would be unrealistic expectations or
unrealistic perceptions of who they are.
They like to think of themselves as being absolutely different from everybody
else.
And you know,
they're a champion.
It's going to happen.
They're going to beat everybody and then they get beat.
They're like,
fuck,
I can't believe I lost.
Like,
and it becomes a real issue.
Read,
structuring their mindset,
like re reestablishing their confidence.
Yeah.
Interesting.
I don't jewelers use one,
I think.
Yeah.
A while.
I don't think he always did it,
but I think he tried it.
David [inaudible],
who I think did it too
well,
the wiser has some real problems.
Right?
Anxiety.
Yeah.
And he didn't have those until he lost,
he lost a retrained Clinton.
That's when all those kids that started it.
Yeah.
I'm not too sure.
I can't.
Well,
that was a brutal fight.
That was,
yeah,
that was a war.
Brutal file.
Yeah.
It was one of Rich's,
uh,
biggest victories and it was when rich was in his prime and it was just a
beating.
Yeah.
David was really never the same after that fight.
When,
uh,
George used it was,
it was post the Matt Serra fight.
I have no idea when it was.
I never really asked him about it too much.
Well,
he seems like the type of guy that we try everything,
he's very open minded,
you know?
Yeah.
And if someone tells him something with Enough Confidence Hill,
be interested in it.
Well,
so I mean,
I was amazed that he was willing to work out with me when I told them that I
could help them with a spinning back kick.
I'm so if I was like,
yeah,
let me get to you on that,
you know?
But he's very open.
He's very,
yeah.
Yeah.
As far as learning things healed,
he has this,
like,
I'll try anything.
He's got the beginner's mindset.
Yes.
Almost too much.
So,
because that's how we got roped into all that fucking witch doctor do rubbing on
his chest butoh moves and shit.
He's very like,
uh,
he's like a child almost in that sense,
you know?
Yeah.
He's,
he's very optimistic in that sense.
Like a summit there.
Everyone's always trying to help him and stuff,
but they were explaining to me what this guy was doing to him that he was like
changing his shockers in his Meridians and all this.
And I go,
Whoa,
whoa,
whoa.
Shit.
Yeah.
I was going,
what the fuck's going on?
I was like,
you're given this guy money.
Hold on.
Yeah.
Explain this again.
What the fuck are you saying?
Do you really think there's one guy that can do this and there's no one else in
the world of the Olympics,
elite athletes and football,
NBA boxing,
fill in the blank.
Millions and millions of fucking billions of dollars on the line and all these
sports.
Yeah.
And there's one dude,
he knows how to rub on your fucking chest and turn you into a sweat.
I heard this guy's,
this witch Dr. Guy.
I never met him.
I'm out of it.
Yeah.
I never met her.
Um,
Dana was the one who actually called him the witch doctor and he,
he claimed that his his name after like Dana called them as a goof.
Yeah.
Like,
Oh you're like a witch doctor.
And then he was like,
yeah,
I'm a witch doctor.
Which doctor
fucking thing?
I don't
know.
I don't know anything about the situation.
I wasn't around for it,
but I'm always astounded the areas that elite high level Alpha male competitors
like fighters getting fucktard but bullshit.
I,
there's been a few guys looking for the advantage.
Right.
Looking for the next thing.
They're really,
I think it's,
it's,
it's in your head.
Oh no doubt.
And one guy I talked to actually admitted to me that what he was doing was all
in your head.
I keep trying to,
like everybody was telling me like,
you know,
I've always had neck and back problems just from Jujitsu and this guy was
working on me and he was like doing some weird shit where he like pressing the
back of my head.
He's like telling me that he could tell like where my issues were by pressing
the back of my head and be like,
does this hurt?
And I was just hurt.
And then he'd be like,
press one spot harder.
It was like,
does that hurt?
I go,
well you just pressed it harder.
And like we had this little like we're looking at each other funny and then I
go,
what exactly you do it?
And we got into like,
you know,
he tried to like get me his spiel and okay,
let's try this again.
What exactly you're doing.
Like what exactly are you doing and what is essentially he was saying,
yeah,
in a round about sort of a way was that if you believe in what he's doing,
then it becomes like a placebo effect.
Placebo.
But I'm like,
but you can't just bullshit me.
You can't bullshit me because I'm too curious.
If you bullshit me,
I'm going to ask questions and I need to know whether or not I'm being
bullshitted.
But it's kind of fucked because if I just let him bullshit me,
maybe I would've had a better result.
But I was,
you know,
I was just like,
fighters like to see these guys.
You see this all the time.
Like with those little plastic wristband with the shiny little tape on it,
like that's going to help me be a better athlete.
Fucking Mike Goldberg.
Michael,
one time we were in Vegas and he had a couple of drinks and he's telling me how
amazing these he's wearing,
what he's fucking stupid things in his room and he's telling me how amazing it
is and makes,
he introduces me to these guys that are selling them and they try to do these
carnival tricks on you.
Yeah,
yeah.
I know,
I know what you're talking about.
They do different little tests with your body,
like pushed down one arm,
but if you understand your Jitsu,
you know he's changing the leverage points.
Like he's like,
he's like doing it like this and then like you know,
he'll like go further out in your arm.
Like now try and you're like,
well you're over there now.
Get the fuck over here.
Do it the way you did it first.
You know,
it's like,
okay,
now resist me.
Okay,
Some people,
oh man,
dude,
Shane had one on Vandelay had one on Caren woman was telling me how it helped us
back.
Mike oversee my back's ever been better.
Two years later you fucking just dissed fused course.
Fuck you talking about man,
this guy's,
he's got a rubber band on your wrist with fucking shiny,
shiny plastic.
Yeah.
I guess maybe it's some people's human instinct to like look for that edge.
Look for that age.
I believe it and believe it and actually feel better.
Actually feel better.
Yeah.
It's crazy.
It's totally crazy.
Yeah.
The mind is so powerful.
It's insane.
It's amazing.
It is amazing.
Some People Power of belief is,
is a,
it's something to be said.
Well,
I was reading this thing where they were talking about injuries and that in
certain injuries,
you know,
people get atrophy after the injury because they don't use the muscle while it's
healing.
Right.
But if you spend x amount of time doing visualization exercises and x amount of
time visualizing actually using those specific muscle groups,
they don't atrophy.
Right.
Yeah.
I've,
I've heard of that.
What the fuck,
man.
Yeah.
You're your imagination.
I think about like all different kinds of things like that when I'm daydreaming
and I find it helps me.
Oh it must,
I mean mindset is so important and we think about the mind is the control panel
for the body.
That's what's executing all those moves.
And one of the things about you when it comes to competition that I think freaks
people out is how calm you stay and how,
how dead.
I'd like that.
That video where you're just standing there staring and not blinking like that
dead eyed calmness.
That's,
that's not giving into anxiety,
that's not having extraneous thought or need to bounce around and beat my chest
before the fight.
You know,
it just doesn't make a difference for me.
But some guys do.
Yeah.
It gets you hyped up.
I don't need to get hyped up,
but like when you think about it,
like the one guy that everybody was so impressed with for throughout his career
was fate or cause he just dead faced to yeah.
He just turns it on when the bell rings.
Yeah,
exactly.
It didn't need to.
And he used to say that like showing anger or showing emotion was a sign of
weakness and that you should be focused entirely on your task and nothing else.
I can agree with that.
But you don't have like,
this isn't something that you've like worked out with a coach or that you think
it's just experience over the years learning yourself.
Is it from observing other people that are also good at it?
I think it's self experience and yeah,
maybe.
I Dunno.
I Dunno why it happened and all of a sudden
just did it was just your thing.
Yeah.
It's just my thing.
You've found your game,
you gotta wash her.
Yeah.
You to go the bathroom.
Go ahead.
It's right through that door.
Okay.
Goddamn athletes and the small bladders.
So what happens though is drinking that water
right to the door,
right on your right hand side,
right there.
Uh,
Rory Macdonald,
ladies and gentlemen.
Uh,
during this intermission,
this brief intermission,
why a Roy does his PPS,
I would like to announce,
well,
actually the show tomorrow night at the Ice House is basically sold out.
I think it's sold out cause it's a ridiculous lineup.
It's Bill Burr,
crystally,
uh,
Brian Cowen,
Ian Edwards,
Tony Hinchcliffe and me.
I do it every year,
every year.
I do a night before Thanksgiving because I'm almost always home with my family
during thanksgiving.
Um,
we actually talked about going places to thanksgiving,
but that seems like a Goddamn nightmare place or nightmare time to travel.
But that shit is a basically sold out.
Um,
and then the next Gig I have to after that is December 12th on the road in
Phoenix,
Arizona with a Tony Hinchcliffe at the celebrity theater.
Uh,
everybody that tuned into a rocky mountain high that was on comedy central.
Thank you so much.
This was,
I think my best one.
I always say that,
but this one,
I really do think it was my best one and it was without a doubt the best
received one.
My last one was,
wasn't it?
I think I just wasn't doing as much stand up while I was doing it.
And um,
for whatever reason,
you know,
a lot of people didn't like it as much.
They felt like I fell off a little bit.
So I worked really hard on this one and uh,
it paid off.
So I appreciate the fuck out of that and I'm working hard as crap.
Crazy.
I just did my first totally new hour this past weekend at the Ontario Improv.
So everybody came down for that.
Thank you.
I had a great fucking time.
And he's back,
ladies and gentlemen.
So when you were 18 and you first started going to Tristar and a,
you made your move up to a Montreal,
how beneficial was it for you as a young guy to be able to train with the
welterweight champion?
It was awesome.
Fucking huge opportunity,
right?
Yeah.
And not only that,
like George was like such a nice person,
like probably one of the more welcoming persons there,
you know,
like he really was like,
oh wow.
You know,
you're really good.
He was very complimentary to me.
Not only let me train,
but you know,
he took me around Montreal,
you know,
talk to me.
Oh,
outside of the gym invited me back to stay with them,
you know,
uh,
for training trips and things like that.
Like,
you know,
such a,
such a cool experience and an awesome part of my life.
Yeah.
He's such a nice guy.
It's incredible.
He really is.
It's,
it's so hard to believe that he's just fucking trained killer.
You know,
he's a piece.
Yeah.
Cause he's so nice.
He's so nice but not worried about competition.
That's what I find fascinating that there's some guys like,
you remember the,
uh,
the whole thing with Rishad and John Jones.
Like they were worried about bringing guys in.
Like,
I'm going to have to fight this guy some day.
You will.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
That's fat.
I find that,
I knew
there are a lot of people now are like asking me to fight him and this and that.
You know,
I think it's,
they don't see the,
the things that I,
you know,
I got to see and I appreciate it.
Not only is like a martial arts,
but you know,
for myself,
you know,
I learned so much from him and I gained a lot from,
his kindness and uh,
what he gave to me and I don't,
I'm not going to forget that and stabbing in the back,
you know?
Right.
What would happen if you
do eventually win the title and George does come back?
I think he just,
you think so?
Yeah.
I'm pretty sure almost 100% offered you a fucking boatload of cash and the two
of you got together.
You know what?
Life's not about money.
No.
Obviously,
you know,
I doing this for money also,
but it's not,
it,
it's never been my goal to be a fucking billionaire.
Right.
I'm going to live in the woods one day and
so are you.
Yeah,
for sure man.
Really?
What are you going to do out there?
I just be weird.
Yeah.
It'd be weird to hear people call me a fucking psycho and just be,
uh,
well,
people probably don't call it a cycle in real life,
cause your real life,
you really normal.
It's just they know you from the moment you step into that cage and that's when
you see what the media shows them.
For sure.
Well,
you know what everybody sees is a fucking camera on you.
You're a fucking psycho.
Let's re look at,
well I'll play that video again.
So you eventually going to live in the woods for real.
Yeah.
Yeah,
definitely.
But that's,
that's the thing that I've been doing,
I've been trying to overcome.
It's like how am I going to train martial arts and,
and live in the,
would live in the woods and have a family.
So I'm going to have to have like some kind of thing worked out.
Well you just got to live close enough to a city.
Yeah.
That's the problem.
I don't want to be close to anyone.
Ah,
how far away do you want to be
far like helicopter rescue for Vl.
Awesome.
What is it about wanting to get away?
Well,
I don't know.
I hate,
I just don't like being in the city.
I grew up,
um,
I grew up in like,
you know,
nature and stuff in my early childhood and stuff.
And then I got tossed around the city,
you know,
having to live with parents that moved,
moved away and stuff.
So I prefer to be out in nature.
Well,
you know what you could do,
you could start your own gym,
you know,
you are at a point what's going to happen.
I mean,
you think about it,
you're at a point right now in your career that if you started a gym today,
people would flock to it and the more you accomplish in your career,
I mean,
wouldn't even necessarily be a gym that you would have to teach at,
but just higher my name.
Yeah.
Use Your name or thought about it.
Maybe an affiliate of Tristar or something like that.
Yeah,
that would be cool too.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I'm just going to see what happens.
It comes my way.
I definitely plan on having a home in the woods,
so I love being in the woods.
Yeah.
You go hunting.
That's so cool,
man.
I bought my dad a both for his 50th birthday.
Oh really?
Yeah.
No kidding.
That's cool.
What kind of,
um,
I forget the name of it.
It's a,
it's a compound bow though.
I lost a few of his arrows,
not measured for me.
Right.
So it was like it wasn't working for me.
Yeah.
That's the thing about
Bose,
especially compound bows,
compound bows very specifically,
you have to get a measure to your draw length and the amount of weight you pull
back and then the arrows have to be weighted to the correct Bo.
No,
you can't have an arrow that's too light or a narrow that's too heavy.
And then you have to site use the,
the site cause it bows have a site on them and that has to be accurately judged
based on the weight of the Arrow,
the speed of the Arrow,
poundage of the poll.
Many details.
There's a lot of details.
I like guns better personally.
Well,
what I like about guns is that they're really effective.
Like I shot a moose a couple of weeks ago and in BC way.
Yeah.
Awesome.
Well,
I'll tell you,
the place is called a big country outfitters and it's like the mid,
mid northern mid be seeing Caribou or something.
No,
I don't think they,
well,
I bet there's some Caribou Caribou.
I was born.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
That's crazy.
It's north of that.
It's a little bit north of that.
And they were about,
I want to say like an a little less than an hour north of Caribou.
That's okay.
Cool.
Fuck.
We saw some big moves to dam.
The one I shot was pretty big.
I mean it was young.
It was only like 900 pounds for a moose.
That's not that big a deal.
He's saying 900 pounds is not that big.
But we saw one,
we saw one that was like fucking Jurassic Park.
We only saw it like briefly for a second.
There was all these females.
There's all these cows.
There were big,
you know,
they were probably 900 to a thousand pounds and this mother fucker was twice as
big as them with his enormous ass,
like this huge legs.
They were just towering,
but,
and then you just disappeared in the woods.
We were like,
Holy Shit.
And they have those out there.
These just giant fucking Mousse.
Yeah.
BCS.
Amazing.
And so many wolves that they encourage people to kill them.
And I know it did become like pes,
but where we were,
the guy,
um,
his neighbor got a cow taken by wolves.
Like they're in their house and they hear how old's and crazy shit and they look
out the window.
It was like 20 wolves ripping a cow apart.
Yeah.
It happens.
They,
they um,
well those aren't bad though,
but there's just a lot of them right now and BC well,
you know,
there's balanced to the ecosystem.
Yeah,
exactly.
And they're very important to that.
Sure.
You know,
for all sorts of reasons to keep rodents down and to keep populations healthy
and to make sure that,
and they catch the disease.
Then animals eat.
He usually in like the,
like the big pack of Caribou that they,
uh,
they usually catch like the sick ones and the weak ones.
It's when they get out of whack,
when there's too many of them and that can happen.
They get on these giant super pacs.
They have a big issue with that.
In Russia there was a,
yeah,
a couple of years ago there was the super packs that were taken out.
Horses,
they were like a hundred wolves strong,
just really nuts and they would,
that's insane.
Take a fucking horse out.
Wow.
Would you live up there like that kind of area up like near Caribou?
Is that where you would live?
Yeah.
Probably Roy MacDonald,
mixed martial arts academy.
Set it up.
People come and live in the woods.
Yeah,
maybe.
That'd be awesome.
Who knows what'll happen?
Well,
you're living in like a pretty metropolitan area.
You're living in Montreal.
Do you live in an like an apartment like in the city?
Yeah.
That's gotta be weird.
That sucks.
You know,
like what is the issue?
Is it too much noise?
Too many people
preferred to be with like trees and lakes and less like craziness and honking
and the anxiety of this that comes along with the city.
Something about it.
And I,
I can't really explain it.
I grew up with it.
Right.
So it's like,
that's what I always look back on it my best times.
Right?
Yeah.
I always find it weird that some people love it.
Like,
uh,
my manager lives in New York City and he loves it.
He loves the screens off the city.
I have to go in the park every day when I trained there to like balance out.
I hate it there.
Really?
Yeah.
Hate the city.
So what do you do?
You just go feed pigeons or some shit.
Yeah.
Walk around,
shout out.
Just relax.
Yeah,
man.
Do you have,
um,
like things that you do?
Like,
do you,
do you meditate?
Do you do anything to try to calm yourself down?
No,
I think a lot.
Daydream a lot.
So maybe that's meditation for me
kind of in a way.
Yeah.
Not Discipline.
It's not like discipline.
Have you ever fucked around with a sensory deprivation tank?
No,
but I was texting you.
I want to do that,
man.
Yeah,
that's right.
And for us,
the ones that do it too well,
let's,
I'll hook it up.
I'm sure there's gotta be a place in Montreal.
I know there's a big place.
Yeah.
In Vancouver that opened up recently.
It makes sense though,
right?
Yeah.
Frankie Edgar was just tweeting me today.
He just did his first session today.
Is it,
it takes like a few times to learn how to relax.
You were saying,
right?
Yeah.
Well I wouldn't say it takes a few times to learn how to relax,
but just to be comfortable with the experience,
it becomes a normal thing.
You know?
It's,
it's so weird.
There's so much,
so much strangeness to it the First Time you do it.
Okay.
Then I think you get more out of it and when you do it two,
three or four times.
Okay.
Like I have one of my house,
so to me going in it,
it's like normal everyday thing.
It's like,
okay,
I'm going to the tank now and I tell my wife,
leave me alone.
I'll be,
I'll be back in a couple of hours and I just go in there and hours.
Huh?
Yeah,
I like to do two hours.
Okay,
cool.
I can do what,
one hour.
Like if I know I have a show,
like if I have to leave the house at seven for a show,
I can,
I can go in at five and go in for an hour and a half or something and take a
shower.
But I prefer it at night when my family's asleep.
Okay.
Everyone's conked out.
I like to go in there because then I know I'm just going to go on my own.
I'm not as no other energy in the house,
if that makes any sense.
Yeah,
for sure.
Like I do all my best writing when everyone's asleep and it's,
you know,
when you have a family especially you're always managing shit.
You know,
like there's always like things like she took my thing calm down,
everybody relaxed and it was like,
you know,
it's hard to write when all that's going on,
but it's way hard to like relax.
Like if I was in the tank and I heard screaming from upstairs,
like got gotta get out of the fucking tank,
who's yelling at who?
Who Do what,
you know,
that would,
that would suck.
So it's,
it's best in a state of complete quiet,
you know,
if you can,
if you can.
Isolation.
Yeah.
Peaceful.
Yeah,
for sure.
And then you enter into it,
it's like,
think about the most piece that you've ever found when you're in the woods and
nature and multiply that by a hundred really as it removes your body,
it removes all the input of your body because you're floating,
you feel like you're flying.
It's crazy as it dead.
It's very intense.
And it's crazy to me that I'm the guy who keeps telling people about it.
I'm like,
how is this not the way more popular?
Right.
It never understood it.
I'm like,
how was it?
Like why do you have to hear from me?
Like how is this not like a huge thing of so many people's lives?
Especially when you think of it,
how much of every boom we were talking about the mind and how much of effect the
mine has on your performance and how important it is to achieve certain
mindsets,
right?
There's no better place to get to know your fucking brain,
the tank.
And I would think with so many people being so performance oriented and goal
oriented and achievement oriented that that would be a huge tool.
Yeah,
it makes complete sense to me.
Right.
We're going to get you in there.
We'll get you in there.
As soon as we get done with this podcast,
I'm going to call it crash.
Okay.
That float lab and we'll hook something up.
Okay,
awesome.
Where are you staying while you're in town?
By lax.
Oh perfect.
Cause he's in Venice.
So again it's like,
yeah,
it's like 15 minutes away.
What?
Awesome.
Yeah,
I'm down.
I'm down here until like the fourth and I leave to Vegas.
Nice.
Yeah.
So you're down here just doing the thing,
having a good time,
getting some training in,
hopefully training with as much people as possible.
Is that when you come into town,
like a place like that?
Is it difficult to raise that or it's everybody just welcome you with open arms?
Um,
I dunno,
I haven't really haven't trained with anyone yet,
so hopefully it's,
you haven't tried that before?
Uh,
in Cali?
No,
that's my next time.
Oh,
okay.
So you just showed up.
Yeah,
I'll,
I'll probably like try to like,
you know,
want to go to check out Eddie's place.
George has spent some time here so hopefully he'll get me a see Freddy and
Freddy Roach.
Yeah.
So and network with people and hopefully I can get a spot with a different gyms
and see what it's all about when that,
how's that work?
Like when you,
when you train with a guy like Freddy Roach,
you have to pay him or does it take in,
you don't know?
I don't know.
Either.
One's fine.
Right.
Just got to get in the work.
Yeah.
If I have to pay him,
no problem with that.
What about Moitai?
Are you looking to do some more time when you're in town too?
Yeah.
Anything.
I'd actually,
I want to learn your sidekick.
It backache,
man.
I'd be happy.
Yeah,
let's work out.
Definitely cool.
Be happy to show you some stuff.
Yeah.
Well you're so flexible already and you throw,
so you have so much dexterity.
We you liked that question mark kick.
You throw out a a lot,
right?
Yeah.
I've been trying to get more dynamic with my cane.
So,
well the front leg side kick is the one that I see making a big comeback in MMA.
I mean Jon Jones loves to do that to the thigh and he even dropped v tour to the
body with the,
I did.
That was an awesome kick.
Yeah,
you're right.
That was a big kick in in my arsenal.
The front leg side kick and I'm a short guy,
but my friend Larry,
um,
my friend Larry Jones who was a high level black belt back in the day,
he was a tall guy.
He's like six foot three and he was all legs,
his legs to his fucking rib cage and this dude would just impale people with his
front leg side kick he just had developed,
have never worked.
I'd love to work that,
you know,
was good.
It as Cajun Johnson.
Oh yeah.
Good Front leg kick.
Yeah,
I definitely like to work that out with you.
it's a weird technique because it's so effective at keeping distance from the
guy,
like a sideways stance.
Like you're seeing that sideways stance play out.
Like Wonderboy is really Stephen Thompson really good at that sideways stance.
Yeah.
He's a really fucking interesting addition to a UFC.
He's awesome.
I've trained with him before.
His striking is amazing.
Yeah.
And he moves like a snake,
you know,
in and ask it back and forth and with a big case too.
That's so,
so hard to deal with the wrestlers.
Well I've always thought,
I always wondered what the UFC would be like.
It was in like a basketball sized place.
Even they're like Metamorris Sao enormous.
Well I don't like men have more is because it gets near the edge and it looks
like people are falling off and like a,
you ever see chrome Gracie versus um,
uh,
what does this Aoki Yacht with the tights?
Yeah.
I had got like right on the edge.
It looked like they were going to separate and chrome caught him with a gay
teens.
Oh really?
He's like a weird like,
sorry to break.
It was a weird sort of it when you know,
crawling gets a guillotine on you,
you're,
you're fucking toast.
He's got a nasty fucking guillotine.
He's,
his technique is so slick,
so hard for to get a surface that works for,
you know,
people want to come pain watch hard.
Well it also,
the cage kind of gets in the way.
A little bit of the view,
you know,
like it's better than the ring at the same time.
Right.
Frame in May.
I think it's definitely better than the rank family man.
I think they're bringing sloppy,
like watching guys fall out of the ring or who was it?
Was it Paulo Filio?
Someone caught someone,
an arm bar where their arm was wrapped up in the rain in the road road.
Yeah.
It wasn't it.
So there's a few guys like that.
Yeah.
That's stupid.
That doesn't make any sense to me.
Yeah,
I guess it's a mess.
And then,
um,
they tried different things.
Like frank shamrock tried some weird thing at one point in time or it was like
sort of like a swimming pool,
like surfing,
it's flat.
And then the judges were like ramped up a bit and then cage.
Yeah,
no,
that was like Yama Yama pit fighting.
No.
Well,
that was Bob Meyrowitz who was the guy who was the first owner of the UFC.
He created that Yama thing.
Right.
And if that's just the fucking name,
like someone should have said,
Yo,
you can't call it
what they're thinking,
you know,
but um,
the idea behind is not the worst idea in the world.
And World Combat League use something like that.
I remember Chuck Norris's organization was kicked by a gang and had some,
Wonderboy was in that too.
Yeah,
he was,
yeah.
He was one of the best guys in that.
Yeah.
That world combat league was kind of interesting,
you know,
some good fights.
Yeah.
And I've seen glory in on spike,
which I think is pretty interesting too.
You get to see,
uh,
some really high level Moitai Thai guys,
but with like slightly different rules.
I prefer the Moitai rules.
I like the fact that they can clench and elbow and,
and hold on and throw in multiple needs.
Exactly.
Yeah.
And Moy,
Tai as an art form is so it's so fascinating to watch because you know,
I'm a big boxing fan,
but the reality of boxing is,
you know,
there are,
there are a masters like a,
like a Floyd Mayweather use it in this incredibly beautiful way to watch you
know,
you,
you use,
you see the way he's using footwork and angles and countering and faints and
it's,
it's beautiful to watch it all pulled together.
But then you see a guy who's like a real,
like a Kevin Ross type,
uh,
you know,
uses everything constantly using elbows,
leg kicks,
knees clench,
throws it all the lion fight.
You watched lion fight.
Lion fight is a promotion out of Vegas.
Like one of the big Moy Tai Promotions in the United States.
They are on access TV all the time.
You ever heard of it?
Really high level guys come over and the fighting,
uh,
like Thai guys are fighting like yachts and Cli fight fights for them about Mala
pet fights for them.
Like real high level Thai guys and they're using everything.
It's a lot of clinching,
lot of knees,
elbows.
It is beautiful because you get to see how this works,
like how you know there's distances where you know you should punch,
there's distances where you should kick theirs.
And then when you see it all combined like a really good,
like a Kevin Ross type dude who's like combining it all together in perfect
harmony.
It's beautiful to watch.
It's such a,
it's,
it's another style of,
it's another art form,
which I think a little bit is lost when you have something like glory where you
don't allow guys to clinch for,
I think they have like a five second rule or something like that.
And you don't have a lot of guys to pull down on the
head and throw.
Nice.
It's bizarre.
And no elbows,
which is another thing that I think is kind of silly.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I'm the same as you.
It's a purist thing.
The less restrictions it better.
And who do you do?
You're more tie with up in Canada for us.
For us.
So for us as your Moitai coach?
Yeah.
Is he also,
does he,
I mean he's obviously a very good grappler himself.
Yeah.
He's black belt and then down here,
does he in,
does he coach you on that too or does he bring it to someone else to do it or,
no,
he's,
he's like my,
he's the guy I go to pretty much for everything.
But yeah,
I'll go around and like I'll work a boxing with a Howard Grad and stuff,
but most like almost everything I do with for us,
we really have a close connection and for us is,
uh,
a lot of people don't understand how skilled he is.
It everything.
He's a really good wrestler,
Jujitsu and kickboxer and he understands it well and he knows how to teach it
really well.
Well,
you could tell just listening to him coach,
you know,
his,
his take on things and the way he described things like when they do interviews
with them,
like he,
he doesn't have a cursory knowledge of it is pretty in depth.
You can,
you can pretty much tell that.
He's also obviously a very smart guy,
you know?
Yeah.
He's got a degree and you know,
he,
he's very,
uh,
he knows how to speak well and express himself well.
Do you see yourself after you're done fighting,
doing something like that?
Do you see yourself coaching?
Probably not.
No.
Yeah,
not interested.
Maybe if the right guy came along or something the right thing.
I probably go onto something else in my life though.
Like what?
I don't know.
Find something.
It's another interest that I want to dive into.
Do you have like a longterm plan?
Do you have like an idea of what your tomorrow just tomorrow you do you know
like when you want to get out.
Do you have an idea?
No clue.
No.
I always told myself I'm just going to do it until I don't like it anyway.
That's pretty much how I operate my life.
My brother laughs at me all the time because I just have like,
I don't have a plan.
I just do whatever's fun and that's it.
That must drive tricks.
Crazy chicks hate that shit.
Are we going to be a year from now where,
what about five years from now Rory?
Longterm plan.
My girlfriend.
She's,
yeah,
she's,
she's a little bit different for me in that,
but it's Kinda balances balances us out a bit.
But you know,
she,
she rolls with uh,
pretty well,
but yeah,
I'm pretty Rad.
No,
like this trip was random.
Totally,
totally random.
I just decided,
I was like,
oh,
I'm just going to stay in California.
So you came out here to compete and said fuck it.
I'm just going to stay.
That was the random aspect of it.
But competing part.
How long did you plan it out to?
Um,
that's actually,
it was when I was training for the [inaudible] fight I was eating and I was
like,
oh,
I was thinking about Jujitsu and I was like,
I'd love to do metamorris.
So I texted a,
I managed to get in touch with them and they're like,
oh yeah,
here's the name.
And I'm like,
okay,
I'll,
I'll overall with him,
do you have to run that shit by the UFC?
Yeah,
dip it.
They accepted right away.
That's interesting.
Yeah.
Cause I would think that like,
you could get an arm broken or some shit like that.
You got caught man pre deep Kamora yeah,
my arm was hurting for a couple of days.
It's just starting to feel better today.
Did you think about tapping?
No.
So you're going to let them snap your arm?
What the fuck?
Like wait,
now I feel like,
yeah,
if like before the match I was like yeah,
I'd probably tap.
But then when I was in the position I was like,
there's no fucking way of tasks.
That's so crazy though.
Yeah.
Well there's that fine line between where you were cause you got out of it.
And you know,
getting it snapped.
Yeah.
I mean that's,
yeah,
I still,
with that particular move it's kind of hard to really do serious damage cause
you know the legs and hips aren't under it.
Right.
But,
but you watch like Frank Mir versus big Nog.
Yeah.
Like Ooh,
that's a hard one to watch.
When you see that was more like her arm.
That was more like the,
it was bent over this way.
Mine was like the straight arm lock.
Yeah.
But still,
I mean guys had gotten their elbows snapped on that.
Yeah.
But that one,
that was August one it was an ugly one.
Cause that when that upper arm snaps for some reason,
that book like here or something,
right?
Yeah.
That's a weird,
real weird Bill Franks.
I'm fucking big guy.
Tank.
Yeah.
And that was back when testosterone replacement therapy was legal.
So you're allowed to be a hopped up on the special sauce.
That's weird,
didn't it?
That was legal.
I so stupid.
Strange.
Yeah.
I can't remember if it was a loud,
well it's strange medically too because it just shows you how you found a
loophole.
What also shows you what a piss poor job athletic commissions do with
recognizing what shouldn't,
shouldn't be legal.
It's insane.
And a lot of the tests they do or like it's like there's like one to one and
then they should be able to test one,
two,
one.
And what's synthetic,
you know,
re being replaced.
They can only test a lot of them only test for like one to six.
So you could be one to one to six synthetic steroids or whatever you're using
and you could still get away with it.
Really.
Yeah.
I heard some crazy stuff like that.
That's why the whole like Vaga and water thing didn't work out.
I'm pretty sure because Vida does the one to one.
Oh,
I don't know what you mean by what?
Like when you're saying one to one,
what do you mean?
Like they could test like your natural teeth.
I'm not super educated on it,
so maybe I shouldn't be open your mouth about it,
but uh,
like they could test synthetic steroids to your natural testosterone levels.
Okay.
Yeah.
Well they're realizing now that they can test for everything,
like which shall sign and got popped.
You know,
the new shit that they're doing it,
he was waiting to answer.
Oh,
well that was during the Anderson Silva fight.
His,
yeah,
his testosterone to epitestosterone,
which I don't understand how that works,
but it's essentially,
it's an indicator that you're using artificial testosterone.
Um,
but he got the most recent one.
We got suspended for two years.
He got popped for EPO.
He got popped for Clomid and all sorts of shit.
Growth Hormone.
I mean,
he was on a cocktail.
That's crazy.
Different things.
Yeah.
I'm in.
Makes you wonder?
I mean,
how it could be better in my opinion though,
for sure.
I think they should test to the maximum ability.
I think that would be the best.
Sure.
But the problem is it's about $40,000.
That's what every blood test like that is.
And they have this chain of custody where they take the blood from you,
they fucking essentially put it in a suitcase,
handcuffed themselves to it,
fly to the lab,
like if they have to come the whole procedure.
Right?
Yeah.
I did the VAT attest name for the Bj Penn fight,
right?
Yeah,
there was,
Bj was a,
he asked me on Twitter,
if you,
if our fight,
we could do the uh,
um,
testing from a whole training camp and they sponsored it.
And so they took all the costs and everything worked out great.
But both obviously passed and yeah.
Beach good.
It was good for this part,
I think.
And that's what George wanted to do with Hendrix.
But you know,
that whole debacle happened.
Yeah.
That was a,
that was a weird situation.
Right.
The,
um,
like George was upset at that after he left and you know,
said that that was one thing that he wants to stand up for.
It was that we need more testing in the USA.
Where was that coming from?
From George?
Like what does,
what does his concern that people are cheating I think.
Yeah.
Right a lot specifically.
Does he know what they're doing or who or what?
I don't know.
He just assumes or maybe maybe I,
you know,
there's rumors that fly around about everyone,
right?
I mean,
I constantly get messages on Twitter like,
oh your cause you have back acne or face acne,
you're fucking steroid use.
They're like,
you know,
I do testing willingly with Bj and I do,
I do vat for every fight.
If I could,
if my opponent would do it with me.
But you know,
rumors I guess.
Right.
Well there's a lot of experts out there.
Fake experts,
ignorance.
There's so much ignorance in there.
But you and me too.
I'm not,
I'm not super educated on it either because there's no point for me to be
educated on,
I don't want to take any part of it,
but I think it's bullshit that people are using it.
Well,
the,
for the longest time mean for how many years was it legal where you're allowed
to take testosterone?
I had no idea.
There were some guys that were guy that was 25.
He was 25.
And you know,
testosterone use exemption.
What the fuck is going on?
Why would you need that?
Well,
all you have to do is get a doctor that tells,
you know the commission,
hey,
this young man has a medical condition and all you'd have to do to get that
medical condition is take steroids.
You take steroids and then you get off of them and the consistent crashes,
your testosterone is low.
Then you get tested,
you have physical proof,
your testosterone is low.
The doctor who was probably unscrupulous says,
yeah,
this young man needs testosterone.
Yeah.
That's,
uh,
it's unfortunate because I,
you know,
martial arts shouldn't be a boat.
You know how physically strong you are,
superior you are to someone.
I think it should be about the technique and skill work.
Right.
That's why I started anyway.
I mean,
do you get like a special satisfaction of beating a guy who's physically
superior to you?
Like you said,
like Tyron Woodley big time,
man.
Well,
it naturally,
I'm not supposed to be better.
I shouldn't be able to kick his ass.
Well,
if you look now with the training and the martial arts that I've learned in the
skill that I spend my whole life working towards,
I'm able to do that.
I able to conquer that.
So it's a special piece of satisfaction for sure.
Yeah.
So if like if you took the average person who doesn't know anything about
martial arts and they looked at Woodley and they looked at you and they say,
all right,
who you betting on?
Everyone tells me,
everyone that tells me,
he's like,
I thought you were going to get fucking steamrolled by everyone,
but why wouldn't you?
And like,
uh,
like just like,
um,
family members that would like watch the highlight video.
They see my highlight.
I'm like jabbing people like maybe picking up slamming them or something is,
it's an impressive highly,
but you look at Tyrone's,
it's just like one shot Kaos everyone.
Like everyone is just sleeping,
getting knocked out.
He's an intimidating figure,
right?
Yeah.
He's a powerful dude.
Now there's certain styles and approaches when it comes to striking and
attacking and you are very technical in your approach.
Like do you have,
have to be,
but you have a knockout power though.
I mean you
mean you mean Stephanie is a tough motherfucker.
You I believe you're the first guy to ever stop them.
Yeah,
I have no idea.
I'm pretty sure you know.
So you are capable of doing it?
Yeah,
definitely.
But like when you hear guys,
like there was a,
there was a dude that I know that I read his Twitter once and he's a nice guy
but he's on his Twitter.
He wrote something like fuck technical striking,
you know,
just standing in the middle of the octagon and let it rip and worse.
What are you saying?
Hockey fight kind of I guess.
Yeah,
I mean I don't,
I mean it was,
the idea was just like test your Kona,
go mano a mile.
I'm a big fan of strategy and technique and technique fighting and that's one of
the reasons why I'm a big fan of you as you like,
you have a very intelligent approach to,
to find it.
Now when you,
when you fight a guy that is just a,
a bull
rusher,
like not saying that Woodley doesn't have technique,
but he will explode on you and it tries to finish shit with one shot,
tries to sprint things like,
do you,
do you have a specific strategy that you use for a guy like that?
Or do you just go with the flow?
I go with the flow and I think that mastering the techniques that,
that you need to use against a fighter like that,
it's important.
Not like thinking,
Oh I have to do this,
this and this against him.
I think just working techniques and every situation possible for a long period
of time,
you'll be able to,
uh,
you'll be able to apply it in this situation.
So I like to react.
Like I try not to think about too much about what my opponent's good at or what
he's going to do.
I just like to work on all different kinds of techniques,
master them and react to what's in front of me at that particular time.
So when you're training for a garlic saf and then do you watch tape on him?
No,
I never watch anything.
I didn't watch JT.
I don't watch Tyrone.
I didn't watch anyone.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's interesting.
Why though?
I don't find it beneficial to me at all.
That's fascinating.
Yeah.
But what if JT had some really bizarre attack he likes to do like you know,
cyborgs tornado guard or some shit like that.
You don't want to be aware of that at all?
Well I think if I'm training what I w w all the techniques,
I'm training it all the time.
I think if I master those I'll be able to overcome that.
You know?
I don't know how to
played it exactly.
That's not a very good explanation.
Study tendencies.
And it's a very big part of their game is studying tendencies and,
and finding openings to suffer.
Ross do that or does Donna her do that for you?
No,
I just kind of,
you know,
I learned one technique at a time and I,
Pete piece it together.
I think over the years and when you master it,
you able to just apply it in this situation.
You know,
you learned your defenses to certain moves,
but if that guy's really good at it or whatever,
you know,
you maybe work that defense a little more.
Yeah.
Well that's why I'm surprised that you wouldn't like,
I'm not sure,
I'm not a believer in footage because you know,
maybe my opponent will change,
you know,
I don't know.
I'm just not into it now.
I could fight a guy that's 600 pounds one day and a hundred pounds the next day.
I should be able to overcome any,
any style of fighter.
That's fascinating.
So when you compete,
you're essentially just putting all of your skill and martial arts knowledge on
the lawn and that's what you like about it.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
That's a better description of it.
Did you always knew that you wanted to be an MMA fighter?
Uh,
once they started training martial arts?
Yeah.
The first day I was,
I was telling Area Hawaii and my last interview.
Yeah.
Pretty much my first day of martial arts thing.
You just knew you're going to be a fighter.
Is there else that's ever attracted
you like that before?
Um,
yeah.
Hockey.
I was really into hockey as a young kid and then I,
when I found martial arts,
I just dropped out of that.
That's an interesting thing about some fighters.
They're not into sports at all.
Yeah.
Because fights are so compelling.
It's takes over everything.
Well,
so it's also so much on the line.
It's so much crazier when you watch a alive UFC fight and you watched some
chaotic wild fucking fight.
It's just the amount of investment that you have in it.
The,
the,
the nerves and the excitement and the like,
just watching it,
just watching it.
It's so much more intense than any of this
boarding your at.
Yeah.
Yeah,
for sure.
Everyone can understand it too.
No one needs to know the rules or anything.
Everyone knows what's going on right away.
The only issue is when it goes to the ground,
like sometimes it goes to ground technical situations.
Yeah.
That's why you guess you find there's a lot of bullying and you know that the
technical striking is coming in.
A lot of people aren't enjoying that.
Yes.
Yeah.
You're seeing it's like waves.
It's really interesting how you see like there was the Mark Coleman wave with a
big powerful wrestlers were taking guys down on the ground and pounding and then
there was the kickboxer wave.
There's a Jujitsu wave and now it seems like it's so varied.
There's some,
there's so many different approaches and strategies going on now.
You know,
you're,
you're seeing wrestlers style and then you seeing like,
you know,
guys like Tj Dillashaw and Dominick Cruz that are accentuating the movement
more.
It's like so much more movement now.
Like if you watch Dominic's fight with me to [inaudible],
there's so much more movement angles in the,
just in that one round.
Yeah.
Giant right.
Movements giant.
Yeah.
I'm a big believer in it.
Well,
when you see guys that are flat footed and they have this very particular Moy
Thai style,
is that bum you out?
Is it like,
doesn't bum me out.
But I mean I used to fight like that did your longest time and when I fought
Carlos that was just like I have one direction,
it's straight forward,
I'm not going to go,
I'm not going to back up.
You know?
And then I kind of opened my mind to new things and yeah,
you have to be open minded and cause every opponent is going to give you a
different reaction,
you know,
it's going to require a different solution.
Yeah.
I also,
it's like there's something poetic about the ability to faint and you add in all
these variables when you add in movement that aren't there.
When a guy is like this flat footed approach,
like Conor Mcgregor and uh,
one of his interviews,
like this last post fight interview,
I asked him,
you know,
I said we was talking about poor Yay.
And I said,
you said he was basic,
like what did you,
what did you mean by that?
Yeah,
that's what he was saying.
He's like this,
this plotting Moy Thai style that everybody does.
And then you see Conor,
he opens up with like a,
a front leg hook kick.
Yeah he does a lot of wild.
Yeah.
I like his style.
It's
super cool.
His style and then his personality is like a weird combination,
you know,
like his style I think is very cool as well.
But like what do you think about a guy like that talks so much?
Shit.
It gets all this attention.
What do you think about that as you do?
You pretty much do the opposite,
but for some reason I kinda like it.
You like it,
but do you think see yourself emulating?
That was not me.
And I think he's being hip and I think that's so awesome.
You know,
he's able to go up there and he's able to uh,
express himself on the mic and in his fighting.
You know?
I think that's,
that's,
that's amazing.
I'm happy for him.
Right.
But I saw like I saw the influence of that in the Dennis Bermudez,
Ricardo Lamas fight,
cause they're in the same division right before the fight.
They were talking all this mad shit and like these guys,
because they want to do that,
they don't shout right.
Well they want the title shot attention and they also see also people can,
real people can recognize when people are forcing it and trying to be something
they're not.
It's the worst.
It's way better to do what you're doing with it.
Dude.
You be you.
And I think people will recognize what you're good at and recognize the special
things about yourself.
You know,
just be,
you.
Be beauty to the fullest.
I think Connor's great at that.
He's not shy.
He's just,
he's him and he's not scared about pissing people off or stepping over.
People ain't know he's doing this thing.
Yeah,
no,
he's,
he's definitely doing his thing.
He's a,
he's a freaky cat and a lot of ways the guys had four fights in the UFC and can
fill up a fucking soccer,
you know,
it's crazy,
right?
He can,
man,
if he fights in Ireland,
if he beats Dennis Seaver and his next fight is in Ireland against a big
fighter.
Well if it's all doe for the title in Ireland,
they might bite that whole country on fire.
They might literally smash every building and light the entire country and has
only been around for a little bit.
It's crazy for fight for fights in the UFC.
That's bizarre.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
It's no wrestlers though.
He has a fun any wrestlers.
Yeah.
He moves really well though.
So that's,
that's uh,
that'll be something,
you know,
wrestlers will have to overcome.
I want to see him versus Frankie Edgar.
That's what I was also good fun.
That's what I want for Christmas.
That's a great Frankie,
cause you're cranky moves so good too.
And he's his,
his uh,
penetration shot is so good.
He's so fucking relentless.
Yeah.
He's like,
we're so blown away by his fight with Cub Swanson.
I thought that was going to be a very difficult fight for both fighters and he
just overwhelmed them.
Yeah.
I like Frankie.
I love that fucking pace he puts on and you see that pace from the moment he
comes in,
he runs to the fucking octagon and he's just,
he's in that mindset like she's just going to start running when the energizer
bunny.
Yeah.
And he's a guy was notorious for training,
like a fucking wild,
notorious like doing press,
all that shit.
Sneaking in workouts and wild,
you know,
energetic workouts.
Also his coach Mark Henry's like very fucking diligent about notes and like
Brendan Schaub trained with him for awhile.
Okay.
They got fucking notes on everything.
Had page after page after page of notes,
you know,
and you see he's constantly working on things and constantly getting better.
I'm,
I'm really impressed by Frankie.
I mean the Bj Penn fight was really impressive,
but I was,
I was skeptical about Bj going down to one 45 first of all.
I was like,
what is he
the fight before they fought me,
right.
70.
What's this crazy fucking nuts?
What is his,
what was it like fighting that guy like that?
That'd be a weird thing for you because you know he's in,
there wasn't,
it was weird because,
you know,
I watch Bj since I was a kid and I always love Bj.
I was like,
man,
this guy's so good.
You know?
He's so cool.
He's such a,
you know,
he's so raw,
right.
It's just hard nosed.
Just wants to get in there and fight anyone.
He fought Machida.
Yeah.
What the fuck and heavyweight.
He's a beef.
It was over two oh five.
So then technically at the same time he was talking so much shit about me and he
pissed me off and I just wanted to eat him alive.
So it was like a mixture of emotions when you heard
him standing probably more than anybody ever did.
You had them in a lot of trouble,
man.
Yeah,
I did it.
He,
he,
he's tough.
He wouldn't go down.
Didn't even know jock Whitney.
No.
He's tough as shit.
Yeah.
He's definitely tough as shit,
but it's hard to watch him take those kind of beatings,
you know?
Yeah,
yeah.
And then the Frankie Edgar beating after that.
It's,
it's hard because,
I mean I don't know who to believe.
You know,
you hear Mike Dolce Chase take on his camp and then you hear Bj's taken his
camp.
It's like I don't hear it.
I don't know.
But I know that Bj,
when he was with the marina bitches and he's doing a bunch of shit that he
didn't want to do right when he was a super uncomfortable and like constantly
sore.
But then you look at what the fuck he did the Diego Sanchez and you look at that
Bj,
the Sean Sherk Bj and he was a motherfucker.
He was a tank at one 55 and then this desire to go down to featherweight.
I just didn't understand it.
It's a bit weird.
Yeah.
Weird.
I don't know what it is.
You know,
just reinventing himself or trying to figure out one new thing.
Yeah,
it sucks to see a guy like that and the last bit of his career is well be hard
to deal with.
What do you think about Anderson Silva?
Like,
he's very skilled,
obviously love his movement.
But when you see him two losses in a row,
both kind of freaky.
Yeah.
Weidman though.
You know,
he's the real deal.
I knew why it was going to give them a hard fight.
I've trained,
I trained with Weidman here and there.
Yeah.
He's a tank.
This guy.
Yeah,
he's a beast.
Yeah.
Well he's a weird guy and he just took home a cheetah and I thought Machida
would be as hard as fight it that way.
Harder than then.
Uh,
and,
and he overcame it.
It was a difficult fight though.
I mean he got put in trouble.
He got put in trouble big time.
Yeah.
My cheat is a dangerous guy and,
but she does another guy who utilizes that strange,
you know,
Machida he'll incorporate more forward stance,
but he'll occasionally go completely sideways on you too.
Yeah.
He had that karate style.
I like to incorporate a lot of stuff.
He does too.
Yeah.
I've always been a fan of him.
He's excellent at that knee.
Check the knee check to the body catches guys coming in with that and to the
body.
He does,
but you don't know when it's coming.
Yeah.
Grown eight down defense to his,
his uh,
his,
his backwards movement to circle out that I like.
I like that.
Wait,
he did some sumo training too,
which is kind of interesting.
So he's really good at like popping his hips forward.
All right.
Circling away from things,
you know.
And he credits that a lot with his take down defense,
which you never think of sumo as like a,
um,
an applicable modern martial arts getting down in your squad at stance.
Right.
You're able to rotate faster.
I do that a lot too.
Do you ever use sumo,
your fuck around with it?
No,
but I'm like,
I've never actually trained sooner,
but I understand the concepts of what you're talking about and I do use that in
my wrestling.
I would like to train it just to wear one of those diapers.
Big Fun,
have some to try to wedge you.
The shit out of me dragged me out of the ground.
Uh,
I watched a while sumo match the other day cause I,
um,
you know,
I watch everything.
I'll watch amateur wrestling,
I'll watch her.
I'll watch karate point tournaments because I think there's something to be
learned in point fighting.
I think there's something about the approach,
the initial blitz approach of point fighting that a,
I forget his name,
but there's a guy,
an English guy who was fighting and Bella tour who's a really good point fighter
who is now starting to fight in MMA.
And there's the,
if you think about like the initial approach of the first strikes that are
landed and point fighting,
it's all about that initial approach.
Unrealistic in terms of like a continuous match or five minute round or
something like that.
But that skill of being able to blitz in and charge in,
it's very different.
Very unique.
Yeah.
Blitzing is a huge,
a huge factor.
I never made a lot of guys are really good at it.
Hendricks as a great blitz.
Uh,
Stephen Thompson,
one of the best.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I think that that is,
um,
uh,
an area where we're going to see some guys make their,
make the transition over to,
uh,
to MMA that have that and that learn all those other aspects of MMA.
But it's hard for them.
The,
they probably have the hardest road in cause at least Moy Thai guys,
they're used to continuously fighting.
They used to taking shots and countering that used to overcoming obstacles,
whereas the karate guys,
it's also,
the stamina is not nearly as much of a requirement.
It's such a much more difficult thing to do and a grounded place for them to
grappling saw leg kicks are hard.
There's a lot,
but that blitz is undeniably effect.
That's just,
I think that you guys ever incorporate that and traits.
Oh yeah.
Do you do,
do drills for that or do you,
uh,
do you ever like deal point fighting?
Yeah.
When Steven used to come up with a towel with George,
uh,
they,
they showed a lot of his blitz style and,
and,
and how to do that.
So yeah,
we've,
we've taken some of their drills for that for sure.
When you train for a fight,
like say if a you have a neat week training camp and it starts out,
do you have like it's set up where like this type,
you know,
we'll like get,
we'll break things down during this period,
this period,
it'd be more like more of a buildup period.
And then like when do you taper off?
Yeah,
everyone's kind of different.
Like,
uh,
you're always excited when you first started camp,
right?
So it always starts explosive.
Then your body starts to break down.
So you need to be able to do a little bit shorter set sessions,
um,
like short but explosive.
So yeah,
there is periods of times where like farther away from the fight,
they're longer sessions but less explosive and intensive,
you know,
more technical approach and drilling and stuff.
And then the closer it gets,
the more time it cut down,
the more just like the hard sparring and work.
And then,
uh,
right before the fight,
um,
it's really short.
You know,
it's just,
it's just a short sparrings um,
the rolling sessions,
things like that.
Maybe some drilling and some pads,
but in between that,
but not long.
Do you ever fuck around with cryotherapy if you'd done that yet?
What's Cryo therapy again?
I know.
Oh,
that's another thing.
I might,
I might have done this.
I got to get you in there.
You go into this part of it 250 degrees below zero.
Yeah.
We put up a fake gun.
Your mouse,
did you?
Yeah,
I did this for my last fight.
Real uh,
yeah,
they uh,
at this,
at my osteo pass clinic,
they got one and I started using it yet.
Is it neck down or is it a full box back down?
Yeah.
You got to go the full body.
I've done both,
but the problem with the neck down one is they don't really get your upper
shoulders and your nap to squat down and hold my breath.
It's annoying.
Yeah.
This one they have in la,
there's a couple of them across the country,
but the one they have in La is insane.
It's full body and I go there all the time.
I'll take you.
Okay.
It's amazing.
Okay guys.
Swear Eddie Bravo turned me onto it.
He fucking swears by it.
He goes several times a week.
Right.
And when he was training for the Hoya Gracie match,
he was going every day.
All right.
He said,
I couldn't do it without it.
He's like,
I need it to recover.
Yeah.
It really speeds things up.
My muscular soreness went way down.
It's amazing.
Yeah.
Like you could have like incredibly sore muscles from weightlifting or you know,
he'll sprints and shit like that and you go in there and it just floods it out
some way.
They explained it to me.
I'm not,
I can't scientifically explain what the details he tells us,
but somebody was telling me what,
what doesn't work and so I was like,
damn,
I an idiot and my fucking fallen for something.
But then I received both the science on it.
The science is a hundred legit because
your body thinks it's fucking dying.
You're going 250 degrees below zero for three minutes.
You're body's like,
oh,
we're fucked.
This is any,
your body tries to preserve itself by pulling all the blood into your internal
organs.
And then once you get out into room temperature,
it's just floods it back out and apparently there's like some intense anti
inflammatory response that comes out of that.
That was amazing for healing.
That is apparently the number one issue when it comes to injury and even disease
is inflammation,
right?
Yeah.
And they're saying that anti inflammatory responses,
um,
and anti-inflammatory,
like diets that don't promote inflammation like low sugar diets.
Apparently sugar is terrible for inflammation.
This was all discovered are all I'm a part of what that whole Regena keen thing
is all about.
I'm sure you've heard of that.
That's like what Weidman had done on his knees.
Dana white talked about it.
It's a blood spinning procedure.
They know about that.
Uh,
it's Kinda like that PRP,
but like more intense,
right?
Yes.
Dana told me about that.
Exactly.
It did.
Prp on my ankles digital because I had bad ankles last year.
They were fucked up from grappling or one was wrestling.
I tore my,
um,
my tendons before the Robbie Lawler fight.
Oh Wow.
After that fight,
I smashed up this one and I thought,
Damien Maia.
So Prp.
Lpt it though now like we see tore it,
tore it all the way through or partial tear.
I think it was a partial,
but it was like I couldn't like walk on it for how long?
Pretty much the whole camp.
Holy Shit.
How'd you get through camp?
Sucked it up.
Yeah.
The shit out of your uncle shit.
Uh,
yeah.
I had a brace and then I taped over the brace.
Wow.
Did you consider pulling out of the fight?
I should have probably.
Really?
Yeah,
but at that point in time,
like I had been like pulling out of every second fight.
It seemed like kind of injury,
you know?
It was like the Carlos fight,
the Bj Penn fight and then before that I had some other small,
before I was like less well known,
I had some other fights.
I was like,
I can't pull it to this fight.
You know,
it's too big.
Isn't that just a part of the game though?
I mean it seems like you just have to push through.
Yeah.
And a lot of fans don't recognize that because not a lot of people want to speak
about their excuses for Louisiana and stuff like that.
He's,
he's going to take it,
you know,
you're never going to be 100% as a fighter and he just have to,
you have to deal with that.
Just got to know what is okay to push through and what you need to like torn
ACL,
things along those lines where your knee gives out and has lost his stability.
Yeah.
I mean,
I could still stand up and throw punches and do take down.
So I mean,
I'm not,
I was still able to fight.
It was just painful.
Is that what it was?
Yeah.
Restricted certain things,
but I was still able to fight.
Now when you have like a,
an injury like that,
do you just figure out a to train around
it,
do you?
Yeah.
Obviously the training is not going to be as good.
Right,
right.
So,
so how do you compensate as far as like your conditioning because that's pretty
much rode a bike for the whole time.
Really?
Yeah.
A biker airdyne like,
yeah,
never done it.
And Yeah,
like a regular uh,
stationary bike.
Just doing sprints and yeah,
two bottles and she doesn't swim.
I couldn't do a lot of stuff.
I do,
I like to do a lot of agility work,
athletic agility and stuff and footwork and stuff and that I wasn't able to do
any of that.
I'll just say George got big into gymnastics.
Did you want up doing any of that as well?
I did it with them,
him and for us for awhile and I never got,
I never stayed with it.
I might start more later on,
like later on,
but um,
I felt it was more beneficial for me at that point in time to,
to work more with John Chamber rather than more the dynamic movement and stuff
and my,
my base wasn't there,
you know,
athletically.
Right.
And Chamber is been your strength and conditioning coach for awhile.
He does George as well.
Well not anymore,
but yeah.
No,
I think George is kind of floats are he?
George does a,
takes a similar approaches.
Me,
it's like if you're efficient in your movements and your skill work and your
technique,
he don't really have to be the most conditioned athlete,
you know?
Right.
So that's more important than this just cardio and in my opinion,
heart rate.
Yeah.
I mean because efficiency is huge.
Right?
And when you're efficient you,
you,
you put out less energy and it's easier.
Like,
have you seen a guy who like a really good boxer boxing guy doesn't know what
he's doing.
Like you're barely even breaks a sweat because he could just keep moving and
loose and your body's normal.
It's your body's used to doing it.
Yeah.
That's,
that's my belief.
But there is,
there is a factor of being well conditioned also.
Sure.
At that high,
high of a level when you have to efficient fighters,
you know,
at the,
at the highest level you need to be in good condition.
Have you ever had a find an altitude?
Um,
yeah.
It's Gallagher.
Is Calgary Calgary out to do it?
Maybe not sure.
I heard Calgary is and I fought there a couple times.
I'm not sure though.
I don't think anything like Denver thing,
like Mexico City was fucking for that.
US.
Oh yeah.
7,300 feet above sea level.
That's how it,
how feed about boulder were where people,
uh,
showing any,
oh yeah,
yeah.
Hunted.
But hunt took the fight on three weeks notice.
Okay.
Reduce,
had lived up there for a couple months.
Oh.
And trained up there,
but I mean hot struggled against Ben Rothwell in Denver,
which is 2000 feet lower.
So,
um,
tough fight for him,
you know,
take on three weeks notice.
And that is a tough fight.
Do you find yourself staying at one seven,
eight or do you think you'll move up?
You got to move up to one 85
yeah.
Not because of half.
Do I've,
I've talked about it before.
It's not because I have to,
uh,
it's just sort of curiosity and uh,
the experience to fight bigger guys,
but I want to do what I have to do it this division first.
So if you win the title at one 70,
yeah.
Then you move up.
Yeah.
I'll probably still fight at welterweight to yell back and forth.
Cause,
I mean it's easy for me to make welterweight.
I'll probably,
if I can,
if I could fight enough in the year and UFC is cool with it.
So essentially for you,
your motivation is challenges.
You want to keep things interesting and challenge herself.
Yeah.
Yeah,
for sure.
I want to overcome obstacles and test myself and find out who I really am.
Do you ever see yourself competing in straight kickboxing or more Thai?
Yeah,
I've thought about it maybe,
you know,
branching off and doing stuff like that.
Maybe a boxing fight eventually and stuff like that.
That would be probably pretty hard for the UFC to agree to though.
Yeah.
But who knows that that what point I'll do that.
It won't be any
damn soon.
Yeah.
Cause rampage is talked about doing that recently.
He's talked about just leaving MMA and Barbara.
Yeah,
I would never do that.
It would be like how I'm competing at Metamorris.
Yeah.
But I just don't see like the UFC ever letting you.
Yeah,
but maybe I won't be fine if I didn't have a name at that point.
Maybe I'll be 40 and so he'd be 40 and take on some more Thai fights.
Yeah.
Who knows?
So you're just a free spirit,
let going with the flow and,
yeah.
Are you enjoying this life?
You've got a wild fucking life man.
Yeah,
it's fine.
Sometimes it's boring as hell,
but what's boring is out of the monotony of training apps.
I like to just always be doing something.
That's her other thing.
My girlfriend has a hard time dealing with.
It's like I can't just sit here.
I have to be doing something.
Well that's gotta be what part of what makes you successful though?
Probably the fact that you have this constant drive.
Yeah.
I have a lot of,
a lot of drive for sure.
Do you read any motivational shit or do you get motivated by anything?
No.
Oh,
I watch a lot of lot.
We'll watch a lot of stuff,
you know,
footage and martial arts stuff that motivates me I guess,
but nothing like,
you know,
art of war or any of that shit.
I have an audio book of Sun Tzu.
Do you listen to it?
Yes,
I'm done.
On the way to training?
No,
not really.
Just kind of randomly.
Oh,
okay.
What about Musashi?
And you ever fuck around with a book of five rings?
No,
never heard of that.
I found it to be more applicable and a art of war,
the art of war,
all the strategy stuff.
I thought it was really interesting,
but it really is,
a lot of it is about actual warfare.
It's not not head to head combat.
Right.
Whereas Miyamoto Musashi was a Samurai and so a lot of his stuff was about one
on one competition and it was also rushy recognizing,
uh,
yeah,
he's,
this is who I have on my arm.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
I've seen this guy before.
He,
well he was this Great Samurai,
fought 62
men and a one on one combat and killed them all.
Just fucking swords.
He would,
he would get bored.
So he would,
uh,
take on people with wooden swords.
They would have a metal sword.
He would use a wooden one.
Yeah.
He killed a guy with an or fantasy or is oh,
no,
no.
Arrow is this,
I believe it was a 14 hundreds.
Wow.
Yeah.
He,
um,
this patient would kill them.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
He killed everybody.
Go written.
No show.
You show up with a sword and he beats you over the head with a fucking,
or he would,
he would widdle the oars down.
I want to say,
what year was that?
I want to say it was the 14 hundreds.
Let's see.
Tim Won't do such.
She,
it was um,
1584.
Yeah.
He died in 1645.
How he was,
I'm 61 years old.
Natural causes probably stomach cancer.
They're saying,
hmm.
I wonder why it says that.
Yeah.
But his book is fascinating because he was really into,
a big part of his philosophy was about staying balanced,
about keeping the mind bounce.
Cause you know,
sword fighting such a fucking unbelievably intense and stressful scenario that
he was all about balancing out your life with art and philosophy and poetry and
even calligraphy.
I mean,
it wasn't about just being this brute and it was all about balancing the mind so
that there was no extraneous stress.
There's all,
everything was about that,
the technique being cleaned,
the mind being sharp and makes us that everything was completely bad.
And he's a fascinating guy,
I believe in balance in your life to,
I'd like to read that.
Do you have hobbies other than that?
I'm in main,
uh,
I like hunting.
Uh,
I've just got into that.
I just got my hunting license this year.
Just this year.
Where,
where have you hunted?
Uh,
well I just went,
um,
up in BC.
Well,
where would Eric,
Princeton,
yeah,
Princeton area up just to get anything.
He got a rabbit.
That's it.
Yeah.
Is that the first time you've hunted a,
as an adult?
Yeah,
as a kid.
My Dad and my grandpa always took me and my brother out,
but uh,
you know,
as an adult,
this is,
this was like the first time I've had an opportunity,
but I'm going to go a lot next year.
Um,
I got a lot of friends that go like elk hunting and stuff and that's all.
I've got a few different offers from some friends that want to take me out in
some trips.
It's going to be amazing.
Well that's the cool thing about being a famous person.
As soon as people find out that you're into hunting,
like I want to go hunt with Roy.
Yeah.
Oh that'll definitely happen.
I got some buddies that are really big into it.
So a lot of UFC fighters.
Yeah.
Chatman was,
he killed his first elk this year with a bow.
He killed the deer to um,
TJ.
Tj killed a huge fucking bear last year and uh,
put it on social media and everybody got angry at him.
Did he eat it in the bear?
Yeah.
People are fucking crazy.
They think you're killing booboo when that he's in the middle of taking picnic
baskets and speaking English and he went up and fucking murdered them.
They don't understand balance and ecosystem and all that stuff.
So you got to educate themselves before.
Yeah.
Well there's a lot of convenience and they're thinking too.
I mean it's just so easy to just look at someone.
You mean?
I had a guy got,
it,
got upset with me cause I shot a bear and he was wearing leather shoes.
I had this conversation with them,
the more,
you know how crazy this conversation is.
So ignorant,
man.
Yeah.
And,
and a lot of them think it's cruel.
It's like,
but the meat you're eating at the supermarket,
do you know,
cruel.
They're treating those animals.
It gets insane.
What's also the getting upset at someone for hunting when you're driving by
restaurants left and right.
You know,
it was fast food,
joints,
supermarkets.
I'm pretty much every crowded street that you drive down everywhere you look,
there's animals that have been killed.
It's just,
it's a ridiculous thing to concentrate on a hunter who takes it in the most
natural look of education,
maybe.
Well,
insulation,
it's a lot of it,
you know?
I mean,
there's ignorance.
I'm sure you deal with a parallel or similar kind of an ignorance when it comes
to fighting.
Because when you tell people that you're a fighter,
they probably assume you're some thuggish asshole and you're like,
wait a minute,
this guy is like,
so like even keeled.
I don't do you get that sometimes where people like they don't understand why
you are so calm and normal,
but yet you're,
yeah.
Elite world class fighter.
Yeah,
I guess so.
Yeah.
There's some situations.
Yeah,
they don't,
they're like,
it's kind of a counterintuitive.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
Do you,
do you ever have people like judge you because of the fact that you're a fighter
or not so much?
Most of the people in the,
now it's super popular,
right?
I call it's cool what,
seven years ago probably wasn't so much.
Oh yeah,
when I was like 14 yeah.
It was that like,
they're like,
why are you doing this?
Go to school,
get a real job.
You know,
like you're never going to make any money.
I'm like,
I bet you I probably will.
I'll make more money doing this.
Then you know,
working in construction or something.
Well now people realize that it's a viable option then it wasn't,
it wasn't popular.
It is kind of a crazy thing.
If you think about people that entered into it when it wasn't very profitable,
like boy,
you have to really love it.
Yeah.
Those guys.
I'm so,
so like thankful for like the Gracies and the guys in the first UFC.
You know Randy,
Tito,
all these guys,
Dan Henderson still,
he's still at it,
man.
That guys fighting Moose Aussie,
he doesn't get enough credit.
This guy,
oh,
it's a fucking animal.
It's one of the toughest guys that's ever walked the face of the planet,
you know,
and these last fight with [inaudible],
but kind of like basically two or three weight classes are bigger
than him.
General ragdolled yeah,
yeah.
It's crazy.
It was so important for those guys to have that passion to pursue this and those
guys really should be heralded as the,
the true pioneers.
They were,
you know,
even though hoists Gracie,
he says a bunch of crazy shit today and like you said,
a bunch of crazy shit about Eddie Bravo's,
my best friend.
I still have nothing but love and respect for that guy because if it wasn't for
Royce Gracie,
I would have never done Jujitsu.
I would never know when it was,
if that guy didn't have the balls to step in there and fight guys like Dan
savage.
And you see him catch a guy on a triangle and you're like,
what the fuck just happened?
Like that opened my eyes so much to what martial arts,
you know what the real potential for martial arts could be and we've seen
martial arts evolves so much,
just enough.
A couple of decades.
20 years more than over the last thousand years.
It's crazy that the amount it's changed.
Yeah.
I mean I was competing in the 80s man and nobody knew anything.
Everybody thought that if somebody tried to wrestle you,
you just fucking catch him with a punch and knock 'em out.
But I thought they would just head kick people.
They were on the way that he didn't realize how easy it would be.
A few to get smashed.
Like nobody had an idea.
I love talking to like back in the day,
like my old kickboxing coach and stuff,
like just just name in the head.
Yeah.
I had a boxing coach that would say,
man,
anybody tries to take me down a sidestep of a cup.
There's this whole thing,
sidestep upper cut.
And I'm like,
yeah,
what if they're shooting at your legs?
How low are you going to go?
Bad idea.
But
making it practical is it whole thing?
Yeah.
I,
this one dude was explaining to me that he didn't need to learn martial arts
cause man,
you know what I'd do?
I kick somebody fucking new out.
Like,
hmm.
I mean I'm going to show you some fights.
One show you Alistair Overeem versus Ben Rothwell.
That knee kick thing doesn't really work that well all the time and it's not
gonna be amazed how durable your knee is and how many shots to the leg your knee
can kick.
Do you fuck around with that will bleed kick?
Do you do that thing?
Uh,
the,
the sideway,
yeah.
That's a,
a kick that's kind of made a comeback over the last few years,
Greg Jackson guys do it.
Yeah,
because you used to see that and those old like wing Chung books,
you know,
they would throw a lot that weird kick and I was like,
Ooh,
that's a goofy kick.
But then,
but you see like Carlos condit likes to do it a lot.
Jon Jones likes to do it a lot.
It's a good kick.
If you,
if you learn it correctly,
Jones is effectively with his other strikes to waist size down and then pup up.
He's so fucking tall too.
That's such a huge advantage.
Yeah.
I haven't played with it,
you know,
but I don't rule it out.
Yeah,
no,
I think it's a really excellent kick.
I like that comes from the same angle,
but it's a head kick.
[inaudible]
crescent or they're crossing care?
No,
it's like it goes up to the,
you know how like,
I do like this front kick,
you know what you do with the heel,
you know,
he just come up on that side with,
oh,
I see what you're saying.
It's kind of a weird kick.
So you're kind of,
it's like a Mr action sort of a thing.
Like they think it's coming and you just,
yeah,
it goes like it's your back leg,
so it comes up this way,
but it ends up like,
oh,
I mean I've had a weird angle.
Yeah.
Like a C,
right?
Yeah.
Hmm.
Oh,
sort of the opposite maybe of the question mark.
Kick.
It's the exact opposite.
Yeah,
I love that question mark.
Yeah.
It's been such a,
you know,
Brazilian kick for some people like,
um,
what was it?
Globby fake Tosa.
Famous though is a piece of that.
God Damn.
He and he used to bring it down.
He was so way out.
Oh my God.
There's some amazing photos of him doing that on mine.
That's a classic [inaudible] technique.
And Taekwondo,
it's,
well that's where I learned to talk window guys used to do it,
but before they used to call it the Brazilian kick,
it was always known as a question mark.
Yeah.
That's such last kick.
We used to call it fake front kick.
Round kick.
That's what we used to call it and talk window.
But you know,
but that uh,
this,
this idea of Ms Direction,
like you see it saw often too with wrestling.
We're guys,
we'll fake a shot and then land a punch and stead,
you know,
there's so much misdirection and fighting to try it.
Yeah.
Faints,
faints or giant.
When you see guys that don't faint and guys that just plow forward with no,
no miss direction,
no fainting whatsoever.
One of the most successful guys as George.
Yes.
Yeah,
very much so.
George was great and it still is at,
you never knew what the fuck he was going to do.
It's crazy.
If people would just be like locked up,
like I don't know if he's going to shoot,
he's going to jab me.
Uh,
he's going to kick me like,
yeah.
Yeah.
George was also great at utilizing the momentum that he got up to being a champ
and just carrying that forward.
He was so comfortable with the experience of fighting in a high profile bout
that you would see guys that were fighting them,
that we're just so caught up in the bright lights in the moment and then womb,
he's taking them down.
Uhm,
he's dropping elbows on him.
Boom.
You know,
it was just,
he was relentless,
relentless.
One of the greatest martial arts martial artist that ever lived ever.
My pepper and a great representative of martial arts too.
Cause he was such a good guy.
And this is such a good guy.
Spoke really well.
Yeah.
I'm happy that he got out when he did and you know,
selfishly in some ways I hope he stays out because uh,
I think it,
I think he still has it in him though.
I think he does too.
But that's what I worry about.
I hate seeing a guy stay too long.
Like the thing that bugs me more than anything is talking to guys that had been
in fights for,
you know,
or in,
in MMA for a long time.
And I see the deterioration that that's hard to watch.
I think if he's patient with it this time,
you what this,
this knee
surgery coming back slowly enjoying the training and then maybe a year or two
years down the road and then he has that he's back to where he was or you know,
where he needs to be.
Could be interesting.
Well it certainly could be interesting cause he'll be having fun with it again.
For the longest time,
I know George wasn't having fun with fighting.
Right.
He's doing it because it was pressure and this and that.
All right.
Well,
he was up to that incredibly high level too,
where he's making so much fucking money.
I mean he's making more money than anybody who's paper views were so high.
He's doing really well.
And he had endorsements and again,
he's such a great representative that people would like scramble to have him
sponsor their product.
It's a sponsor him rather.
Right.
But I,
I just think that there's a certain amount of punishment you can take any career
and then past that,
you know,
there's,
there's a point of no return,
you know,
and I worry about that cause he's so well spoken.
It's such a good guy.
I worry about guys getting to that point of no return.
Is that something that ever comes into your mind?
No,
it doesn't bother me.
But when you see like these studies on traumatic brain injuries in the NFL
players and yeah,
I'm not an NFL player or even in fighters.
You hear about an fighters as well.
Yeah.
I think it also has to do with some certain styles of fighters though.
I think,
uh,
guys like me take a lot less damage with,
um,
if I felt like I did against Carlos and all my fights,
I'd have a short career and then I'd probably have to be concerned with some
effects down the road.
Like Forrest Griffin style,
Forrest Griffin versus Stephan Bonner.
If you look at my fights are the statistics on my phone,
I don't get hit much.
Right.
You know,
so it's,
it's not a huge issue for me.
Well,
you're good defensively when you do get hit too.
Like you were one of the few guys like Robbie tagged you,
but you figured out a way to maintain your cool.
Yeah.
Stay calm.
Who's that the most you were hurt in a modern fight.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I was okay though.
You know,
I wasn't,
uh,
I,
I was definitely hurt.
Like the shot bang gave me like a,
you know,
my eyes went back or whatever and I fell on,
but I remember I was thinking clue clearly through the whole thing.
And I remember my legs being so tired at that point of the fight that I just
needed to go down.
You know,
so I think,
I think actually,
um,
uh,
the more scrap,
the a bigger hit for me was the Carlos condit fight.
He hit me in the temple and the top of the head and I was just like,
so scrambled man.
It's weird how different spots in your head we'll do that isn't it?
Yeah.
The side of the head to is really good.
The temple,
I like to target that area.
It does something weird to equilibrium,
right?
Yeah.
If you,
if you look at um,
my Naco it against a pile and Safra name,
it was pretty much similar.
I finished them,
I got um,
the mom four points and I would give them shots to the temple,
um,
sitting over top of them and when they both got up,
they did the same thing.
They would get up and they would think,
they would find their legs would give out and they keep going back and forth,
side to side and they have to have a guy hold them up.
I think there's something to say about that,
that,
that shot,
that impact there.
Yeah.
We were just talking on like someone was talking online,
we were talking about like what shots hurt guys and what shots don't hurt cause
there's no rhyme or reason to it.
Like sometimes you'll see a guy get caught with like a grazing shot to the
forehead and his legs just give out.
Right?
Yeah.
A Conor McGregor was kind of like that when he knocked on Korea.
Perfectly.
Yeah.
Can I just like hit him there?
Interesting.
Okay.
Yeah.
Car Hits fucking hard for that weight class.
It's crazy.
He hits very hard for that weight class.
I always wonder if he's going to stay at one 45 or if it becomes too much of a
struggle to get there.
Yeah.
Who impresses you these days?
Like I know fighters like Woo Hoo.
Do you like watching?
Um,
I've been watching a lot of Ronda Rousey or Judah.
I want to get good at that.
Uh,
Connor's movement,
um,
punching style.
It's interesting how he keeps his chin up in the air a little bit,
but um,
his apricots and his movement after that.
Cool.
He's a very John Jones,
how he mixes things up with,
uh,
you know,
his elbows and his distance and stuff like that.
Ground and pound.
John's very creative too.
Like I love that move that he did with Glover where he ranched to shoulder and
a,
I go,
do you ever done that before?
And he's like,
nope.
Just kind of made it up on the spot and knew that it was a vulnerable,
I knew there was something not supposed to do in wrestling and so we just
realized that glow over had a light under hook,
just got his forearm behind the elbow and just yank the shit out of it.
Tore Glover's shoulder up crazy.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He'd just have to go with the flow,
I guess.
Do you like water like Bruce?
Yes,
exactly.
I find it fascinating when you see a guy,
like one of the things I'm really fascinated by is,
um,
Gustafson and rumble Johnson.
Okay.
Because Rumble Johnson who was a standout at welterweight now fighting 35 pounds
heavier,
how I fucking,
he's huge.
He just,
he just died the shit out of himself.
He's a perfect example of you can cut too much weight and it actually fucks you
up.
Like the point of diminishing returns.
He had passed that clearly.
Yeah.
I Dunno how he grew so much.
Same with Overeem.
That's great.
Well I know how over him.
I think we know rumbled did it too.
I don't know.
I mean rumble was always big.
Like when I caught,
I saw a rumble.
Yeah.
Between fights once and he was two 30 pounds.
Yeah,
you're
right.
You're right.
I did see him in between fights.
He was massive.
I think he was just incredibly disciplined and dieting and starving himself down
to 100% worth it at that point.
Bigger guys who carry it fucked him up.
I mean when he lost a cost check,
he just had enough in the tank.
It got to a certain point where his body,
he was good for a certain amount of of effort,
but his body was so depleted and not saying taking anything away from cost cause
cost check legitimately beat them.
But your body,
when you,
you have so much depletion,
there's a certain point in time where your body is like,
you know what?
It stops.
There's nothing left.
It's just not functioning right.
Right,
right.
And at light heavyweight,
he's a motherfucker,
man.
Yeah.
Who'd want to fight like I,
I'd have no interest at fight at one 55 yeah.
It's zero interest.
So all the guys do it,
man.
I'd way rather fight bigger guys.
Yeah.
I don't have any interest in losing that much weight.
You look at Frankie,
I mean Frankie,
for the longest time when he was a lightweight champion,
he was weighing one 55 fighting 55 yeah.
That's funny.
Yeah.
He barely cuts to make one 45 he can make one 35 really?
Oh,
100%.
I guarantee you he can make one 35 yeah.
It wouldn't be fun,
but he could do it.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
That's cool.
It's,
it was a good decision.
It moved to a 45 though.
Yeah.
Huh.
Anybody else that is exciting to you?
Okay.
There always is.
You know,
like,
uh,
I've watched a lot of Bruce Lee.
Did he really?
Yeah.
I leave my show.
Every fighter does.
Yeah.
I Dunno.
A lot of older guys too.
I'm very random.
The newer guys though,
I like,
I've been watching Connor and Ron did a lot lately.
I love Ron.
His arm bar technique.
Yeah.
I think her arm back technique,
it might be the best I've ever seen.
Yeah.
She's got a great arm.
Her setups and the way she's able to adjust when opponents tried to roll out of
her or moves,
like as they try to get out of it,
she just sinks it in tighter and tighter and tighter and she follows them.
She's so used to attacking with armbars that like,
she kinda knows what they're going to do before they know what they're going to
do.
So as they try to defend,
she's like one step ahead of them.
Yeah.
Tightening it up even further.
Jordan Burroughs,
I watched a lot of him to wrestling,
you know.
Yes.
No,
Jordan Burroughs,
um,
great American wrestler.
I think he won the Olympics and world championships a great explosive double,
probably one of the best double eggs around.
Interesting.
Interesting,
interesting style.
He watching him and hearing about a lot of his techniques helped me a lot in my
wrestling.
Well George was really interesting and his wrestling approach,
because he didn't wrestle in high school,
did wrestling college and trained a lot of Russian nationals up there in
Montreal.
Right?
Yeah.
He trained with,
yeah.
The,
the,
the Montreal team.
Yeah.
Is there a lot of high real high level wrestling up there?
Uh,
yeah.
I,
I'd say I like,
um,
you know,
[inaudible] I can't,
I never able to say his last name.
[inaudible] sorry man.
I don't know.
He's a world champ and I think Olympic silver medalist,
he's a super technical,
he's helped me a lot with the wrestling.
I think he's helped George a lot.
Um,
yeah,
there's a lot of,
there's a lot of good wrestlers there
and is us bring guys like that in,
does he have like wrestling classes?
Yeah,
yeah.
Kia comes in and there's also some other wrestlers that come in and uh,
there's,
uh,
some Greco guys that come in now.
Yeah.
Well,
it's just such an amazing sport.
I love MMA.
I just love that there's so much variation.
There's so many,
so many variables to consider,
the so many different options and different approaches.
It's just constantly exciting and interesting to me,
you know,
and so much to learn there is,
and I love that this guy's like you man that are out there.
You're on the edge.
You know,
you're,
you're constantly pushing it and just really fun to watch a fight,
man.
Thanks.
I really appreciate it.
I really appreciate you coming on here too.
It's fun.
Good conversation.
Thanks for the plug at the beginning podcast.
Check it out.
That's Rory Macdonald.
And if people want to follow you on Twitter,
what is your Twitter?
It's Rory Macdonald.
Macdonald.
Not Mc.
It's Mac.
Yeah.
You don't want some dude out?
They're faking it.
It's just some dude out there pretending to be you,
sandy buddy.
Oh yeah.
I'm sure all that.
So the other thing I wanted to talk to you about before we leave the music
fucking music,
the walking music,
we've talked about this on the podcast is a great story.
You changed your phone number and the UFC did know that you had a new phone
number.
So they were texting your old phone number and some other dude who got your
number,
who was a fan was he was picking your walking music.
So when I moved from [inaudible]
Colona BC,
the small town,
I was doing martial arts,
that when I finally made the move to Montreal,
I had to switch to that,
the area,
right?
The phone number.
So my old phone number went to this random guy in Colona and uh,
apparently he was a fan of me.
And uh,
um,
Jason,
the guy,
uh,
at UFC who is asking for my entrance music just had my old number.
And uh,
and so this guy was,
he was like,
hey Roy,
what's a,
would entrance music do you want for the next fight?
And this guy was like,
just picked up on it was like,
hmm,
pretending to be me.
And so he kept giving him my entrance music.
So for the longest time I kept walking out to the most random,
the best one was the MC Hammer.
You made fun of me.
He was like,
this shit's
terrible.
It's all you.
Yeah,
he made fun of me for that.
What would you fight?
Who was it that you liked?
Paul,
Mike Pyle and Mike Pyle came out to some classic songs.
A rocky.
It was because it was in Philly.
We fought in Philly.
Oh,
that's right.
So I said it was classic and then Mike Goldberg was like,
well this is classic too.
I go,
yeah,
but this song sucks.
Which is kind of a bummer cause I saw MC hammer after I said that,
I saw him like a couple of fights later and he came up to me and said,
I'm like,
Huh,
I feel bad now.
I said,
your song sucks.
So I'm back in the day.
But
yeah,
I mean it's not my kind of music,
but some people like it and apparently this certain fan enjoyed the song.
I thought I would enjoy it too.
Which songs did you choose?
Here's some songs you had a Metallica seek and destroy me.
Rihanna is me.
Okay.
So you picked those all the way up to Mc Hammer,
Mc Hammer.
Did you pick up,
uh,
did you know Tupac and Biggie?
Was that you?
That was me.
That was you.
That was the one probably where I,
I caught onto it.
So Mc Hammer was the catalyst.
Yeah,
it was the last one.
So that was the last that guy picked.
And the one I,
I,
uh,
the Tupac and Biggie Song.
Yeah,
that was a,
when I fought Shane mills and Jason came up to me and he's like,
and it would've continued on if this didn't happen.
He comes up to me in person.
I was like,
oh,
sorry,
Roy,
um,
we can't get the rights to that song.
Um,
whatever it was.
It was like a Nickelback song
and
yeah,
so it was like,
what are you talking about?
And uh,
he was like,
yeah,
you go,
you asked you,
I texted you,
you told me this song.
I'm like,
dude,
I never texted you or anything.
And we started arguing like,
he's like,
yes,
you did.
And I'm like,
no,
I didn't man.
And I'm like,
pull up your phone.
Let's see it.
So he takes his phone out and he's like,
look,
he said it right here.
I'm like,
what number is this going to the contact,
see what number is it was my old number.
I was like,
dude,
this is not my number,
man.
Paul,
your
old number and talk to them.
Oh,
I should have though.
Fuck yeah,
we should call him right now.
We should.
Does he still have it?
What is my El Norte?
82 still bombed on.
We should call him.
Call him after the show.
We don't want to fuck with that dude.
I got to figure out my old number.
Old.
Just text Jason.
Ask him if he's still might've deleted it.
All right.
Anyway.
Oh No,
I remember that number.
You got it?
Yeah.
Okay.
We'll call it afterwards.
Rory underscore Mac Mac Donald's.
Follow him on Twitter.
When's your next fight scheduled?
You're waiting while you're waiting for the title fight after title fights over.
You get to Johnny.
Johnny Hendricks Fighting Robbie Lawler.
December 6th two weeks from now.
The winner of that fights me.
Beautiful.
On a date to be disappointed,
hopefully in Canada,
right?
They,
Dana said it's for sure in Canada.
Oh,
wow.
So will that be in Toronto or Montreal?
Toronto.
Calgary,
Montreal,
Vancouver.
Right.
There's a lot of spots for you.
Wow.
Listen man,
there's a lot of fun.
Yeah,
it was.
And uh,
I really appreciate you doing it and I appreciate your style.
Love watching you fight.
I'm a big fan.
Thank you,
sir.
This is cool for me,
Rory Macdonald.
Ladies and gentlemen.
All right,
we'll be back tomorrow with Lewis from unbox therapy.
Until then.
Take care.
Bye.
Big Kiss.